nick lane is a biochemist a writer and a
professor at university college london
whose book transformer exposes on the
origins of life not being so heavily
contingent on rna as many think but
instead in something called the krebs
cycle poetically you can think of this
as the difference between an information
theory of life which is the current
dominant view to one of the
thermodynamic energy flow of life which
is nick lane's view as usual click on
the time stamp in the description to
skip this intro my name is kurt jay
mungle i'm a torontonian filmmaker with
a background in mathematical physics and
this channel is dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything that is primarily
from a theoretical physics perspective
so for example grand unification and
quantum gravity but as well as
understanding the role consciousness has
to play to the fundamental laws provided
these laws exist at all in a form
knowable to us two quick announcements
firstly there's a physics and
consciousness contest on this channel
the link to which will be in the
description as well as the thumbnail is
over here essentially it's the physics
version of the three blue one brown math
contest except ours is for physics and
consciousness as well if you have an
idea for some explainer of an advanced
physics or consciousness concept then
think about creating a video for this
and submitting as you have the chance to
win one thousand dollars brilliant has
come in to give five thousand among the
top five so that's one thousand for each
the second announcement is that there's
a new theories of everything.org website
this is a website where you can support
toe
curt which is me
instead of on patreon because patreon
takes a huge cut as well as paypal takes
a cut there's many different places that
take their share and as a creator you
don't have control over your donations
so for instance
patreon may decide to shut you down for
whatever reason they like there are also
a variety of benefits that come with
being a member on the toe website for
instance you get an ad free version of
the shows that are coming out an audio
ad free version that is to say you get a
private link to the rss feed to download
the audio versions and they come out
about 12 to 48 hours sometimes even one
week prior to you seeing them here on
youtube just so you know the way that it
works is that i finished editing and
then i have to do another run through
and go through time stamps and catalog
references and so on that takes time and
what it means is that i put it out on
youtube and then i have a lag so that i
can build up some hype and some audience
prior to the premiere but then that
means that i've actually finished the
episode a couple days before so what
i'll do is i'll upload simultaneously
for the members an audio version ads
free and then later it premieres on
youtube
for you as the youtube audience nothing
changes this is the way i've always done
it it's just that i have here an audio
version for a little while prior which
i'm going to release to the tow members
as a thank you and it's going to be ads
free so that's one of the benefits from
this point forward there may be
mid-rolls that is ads in the middle of a
podcast and that's just part and parcel
of the toll members of the tow audience
you are sponsoring toe and then the
sponsors also sponsor toe so thank you
for your support those won't be there in
the audio ads free version for the tow
members second benefit is that you get
discounts to any live events when we do
have them for instance i'd like to do
carl fristen in london live in front of
an audience same with ema gilchrist and
john verveicky at some point another
benefit is that there will be exclusive
merch offered to the tow members another
benefit is that there's a number to text
me again if that's what you're into
we're testing this out for about a month
and yes this is something where i am
texting you back to your phone
throughout much of this you can see that
the artwork here is exquisite on the
website and that's because it's been
done by boris martinez costello a link
to his instagram is in the description
as well thank you boris thank you so
much as for today's sponsor it's
brilliant brilliant.org now brilliant
has been with toe since near the
beginning i recommend you check out
brilliant.org toe if you're interested
in learning math and physics and science
so brilliant is a place that you go to
learn about stem subjects in an
interactive manner they have these
bite-sized courses it's extremely easy
you may think that special relativity is
beyond you no it's not it's something
that someone can understand in
elementary school the way that brilliant
breaks down these
extremely ordinarily extremely advanced
concepts is elementary at some point
i'll be doing an introduction to
information theory in particular there's
david deutsch and chiara marletta's
constructor theory and because i'd like
to learn that i decided let me brush up
on the fundamentals of information
theory and i took brilliance course just
to do so over this winter break visit
brilliant.org toe that's t-o-e to get 20
off the annual subscription i recommend
that you don't stop before four lessons
just keep going until you hit four and
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking okay thank you and enjoy
today's episode professor thank you so
much for joining me on
on toe thank you so much it's my
pleasure thank you
why don't we go over your primary thesis
about how the krebs cycle predates life
and
perhaps you can contrast that with a
reverse predominant view which is that
genes cause metabolism or genes create
metabolism or the conditions for
metabolism yeah i mean this is a this is
an argument that goes back decades in in
work on the origin of life and and you
mentioned the krebs cycle already um
those ideas also go back decades this is
nothing particularly new uh from me um
but
what's changed is that there is now some
experimental evidence um and that's been
lacking so
i guess the the whole field of biology
has been obsessed with genes and
information over
since the 1960s since the code was
cracked
and and the idea that rna
which is the kind of the template
taken from dna it can it can catalyze
things it can also
supposedly copy itself it can act as a
template for itself and so on so it's a
beautiful idea it's called the rna world
it's been around for quite a long time
now
uh and it kind of takes you further and
further away from biology as we know it
and i end up in a place where as a
biochemist i'm i'm i i just don't
recognize the landscape
um
so these ideas of metabolism first
i suppose the problem there is that it
asks a lot of the environment
effectively it's asking
one specific place one specific setting
to start out with something like carbon
dioxide and hydrogen and not much else
and to make everything from it in the
absence of genes in the absence of
enzymes it's it's it's a big ask
um and uh and people who've argued this
harold morovitz one of the great um
biophysicists who worked a lot on the
origin of life he he linked it in with
metabolism first and the krebs cycle
very early
and he was largely dismissed because
there wasn't any any serious evidence
that it could actually work
and now what's happened over the last
five or six years is is it's beginning
to look as if it really does work and
it's not just the krebs cycle not as a
complete cycle but as a kind of a linear
pathway with parts of it it's not the
whole thing
um but also other core biochemical
pathways seem to just spontaneously
happen
and they make so much more sense
of the whole structure of biochemistry
and then also how it is that information
comes into biology because it comes in
it comes in
in a context where it's already
optimizing things that are happening
anyway and so there's there's a kind of
a
very easy shift to information and
natural selection as we know it
do you see the metabolism question or
solving
metabolism as being a biochemistry
question or physics question or a
biology question
yes
are those distinctions important
they are important from the point of
view of people's backgrounds they're not
important from the point of view of the
question because the question is a
question in science the question is it
needs physics it needs chemistry it
needs biology and geology and so on and
this is part of the problem
uh that it's been a kind of collision of
disciplines each of which have
you know 100 years or more of its own
intellectual history and ways of seeing
the question
so i think
the the dominant
way of seeing the question over the last
really since the miliary experiment in
1953 has been through the lens of
chemistry and what the chemists have
tried to do is what synthetic chemists
try to do which is to say
you tell me i need to make a nucleotide
so i'm going to make you a nucleotide
i'm going to make you nothing but
nucleotides it's going to have a high
yield it's going to be pure i can make
you 70 and i need to start with cyanide
therefore this is how life starts
and from a from a biologist's point of
view
um
well you'd see it the other way around
you'd say well natural selection
optimizes things that
um that you know were worse at the
beginning and now they're better because
selection optimized them uh and
therefore what we're looking for is a
process that kind of works a bit but is
really very bad um that means i want a
low yield it means i want low purity uh
you know it it kind of turns a hot it
would it would it would bring any any
self-respecting synthetic chemist out in
hives to try and do it that badly
but that's really what a biologist wants
to see what a geologist might want to
see is well what kind of an environment
is conducive to
um any of these chemistries
are there settings on the ancient earth
that are
conducive to
cyanide for example or to co2 or
whatever it may be so there's this this
collision really between disciplines and
ways of thinking about it and we can't
all be right
and people have spent decades of their
lives
um
seeing seeing a question from a
particular point of view
and it's it's very difficult for any
human being to kind of step back and and
stand on a soapbox and say well i got it
all wrong i've just wasted the last
three decades of my life
often the answer is somewhere between
between different theories different
hypotheses it's a bit of this and a bit
of that but you can't test that you've
got to be purist about what you test
um and and you know most of us are going
to be wrong about most of it and and
that can mean that you end up
with
quite unpleasant personal animosities
between the researchers in the field
okay so the chemist or the synthetic
chemists see that there are certain
building blocks to life and they want to
create those in the lab artificially or
starting from simpler ingredients and
then the biologists say no well look if
we have these ingredients the way that
evolutionary biology works that we start
from something that's less pure and then
we work upward
yeah the real the real the real
difference here i suppose is is that
what the chemists have done is is
it's as if you say
right we need we need nucleotides the
building blocks of rna and dna we need
amino acids we need to have fatty acids
the building blocks of membranes and so
on um so
so so go make them for me and the
chemists go away and they make all of
these things um and they've they've
started with co2 but it doesn't work
very well the yields are low and so on
so they put that aside as unworkable
chemistry and they start with with
cyanide or something which is very
energetic but i mean large amounts of
cyanide you're practically asking for an
atmosphere which is just saturated with
cyanide
and
and the chemistry works it produces the
building blocks of life but by with a
starting point that no life ever uses
via pathways that life never uses and so
it kind of leaves you with the same
question which is to say okay so if
that's how it started then you end up
with an environment that's got all these
building blocks floating around you've
got the perfect primordial suit but but
then what happens and there isn't really
an answer to that it has to i mean you
may as well say then a miracle happens
everything has to self-organize
whereas
why does it invent biochemistry as we
know it if that's
the worst possible way of doing it so
what
what i have been looking for as a
biochemist and a bunch of other people
is
do these pathways at the core of
biochemistry happen spontaneously in the
right environment not very well just a
little bit but
whole you know pathways with 10 15 20
steps in them that you might say well
that's asking a lot of the environment
can it happen though and the answer is
often yes
um
at levels that were undetectable 20 or
30 years ago but you know we're in a lab
we're we're doing we're we're looking at
a very small subset of possible
conditions we don't really know what the
right conditions are so to make it
happen at all is a big step forward
the issues with the synthetic chemists
is that they can produce the building
blocks of life but then they don't show
a way of how those building blocks
interact in order to create life or that
the conditions necessary to produce
those building blocks are so unrealistic
uh to my mind and the chemist of course
would disagree
and and you know we don't know so much
about what the early earth was really
like so
they probably have a point
um but to my mind the it's not
consistent with what we do know about
the early earth it was mostly a water
world mostly an ocean there was there
was probably one to ten bars of co2 in
the atmosphere it's highly doubtful that
there was very much cyanide if any um
perhaps there were some and and the
pathways that they've come up with look
nothing like biochemistry as i know it
as a biochemist and so even when you've
answered the problem you've still got to
say okay so so how did life start then
you you've got all the building blocks
but then what happens next
whereas if what you're looking at is a
is an environment which is kind of
dynamic and continuously you've got a
continuous flow in say a hydrothermal
vent you've got a continuous reaction
going on and remember that you know we
are
we are a continuous chemical reaction if
you put a plastic bag over your head and
start breathing then your continuous
chemical reaction stops
uh and and life stops so
we
breathe we have lungs we have a
cardiovascular system we've got all of
this sophisticated way of making sure
this reaction is happening in each and
every one of our cells
so take all of that away and say well
how can you have a continuous chemical
reaction that's happening which is
converting the environment into more of
me you might say
uh and the answer is well you need a you
need a dynamic environment something
like a hydrothermal vent where you've
got a continuous flow of reactive things
that are mixing and and reacting and
producing structures right there
when you use the word pathways or
biologists use the word pathways is that
referencing the step by the recipe that
creates
some end product
what is the word pathways yes sorry
this
a lot of people have seen a metabolic
map which kind of is like the the you
know map of the london underground or
something except
a whole lot worse
really detailed
um
lots of names of particular chemicals
with arrows going from one to the next
one and names of enzymes connecting up
the arrows so a pathway would be you
start with this compound you end up with
that compound and there's 10 steps along
that way and and you link them all up
and that's the pathway that's a
biochemical pathway which starts with
this substrate and ends up with this
product and it links them up in a way
which all life does pretty much in this
in the heart of biochemistry it's
universally conserved not always the
genes or the enzymes but the chemistry
itself that underpins it is almost
always the same across all of life ah ah
so you're not just looking for the
products you're also looking for a
similar pathway exactly or a pathway
that's similar enough that conceivably
with variation it could have moved on to
what exactly okay yes
yes
and this this all together is is is
we're talking about scores of reactions
maybe a couple of hundred types of
reaction all linked up in very specific
ways which we see in life which is now
encoded by genes
but the
you know the question of how did those
genes come to encode that metabolism is
a really difficult question unless
you're able to turn it on its head and
say well the metabolism happens first
all this well this network of reactions
is spontaneous in the right environment
and the genes kind of emerged afterwards
and sped it up and optimized it and you
know
improved it
okay and part of the reason why it's
strange to think of genes first
producing the metabolism is because the
way that we think of genes is operating
is sequentially incrementally and these
pathways are so
well it would it's difficult to think of
half of a krebs cycle or half of one of
these steps as working
um
yes and if you if you take it that way
um
i mean there are various ways of
thinking about this but but how how does
a pathway let's say you've got 10 steps
in this in this biochemical pathway
and let's say it's invented by genes
how
what what do those genes
do
so there's two main ideas one of them is
well you've got plenty of the product in
the
environment but let's say there are
organisms out there and they're
beginning to eat that product in some
way and so now there's less of it so if
you if you can come up with a gene which
takes the precursor to that product and
converts it into the product then you've
got
an advantage
so you kind of start at the end of the
pathway and work your way back one step
at a time or you can do it the other way
around you can start with the precursor
and work your way up one step at the
time but both of those ideas basically
assume that all of the intermediates
along that pathway exist at high
concentrations in the environment and
that you can get at them and that they
are useful in some way and
you know all of these are very hand
waving ideas and there's basically no
truth to any of them
whereas if what you're assuming is that
actually
going from one to another along this
pathway at a low level
it just happens you know these things
just interconvert into each other
there's not
and so
at that point a gene which which speeds
up any step will tend to
will tend to increase the whole pathway
so it's much it's much easier as a
question in evolutionary biology about
how how do you then um
kind of ramp up you because all you're
doing is increasing the flux through a
system that exists anyway
and where does energy enter into this
the way that i understand your the
difference between you and how biology
ordinarily thinks is with regard to
information based is the biological way
of thinking and then yours is energy
based so i haven't heard energy come
into this and i'd like to hear it yeah
yeah
so
so the way that life works generally if
you look at the tree of life and this is
another
way in which biology has kind of
intruded into the question of the origin
of life over the last couple of decades
um
what does the tree of life say about the
very base uh the the kind of bacteria
that are the most ancient the the very
first ones they're not the very first
ones these are things with genes with
enzymes they're pretty sophisticated
cells this is the common ancestor of all
of life as we know it
and you could say well it's not got much
to do with the origin of life or you
could say well perhaps it points in that
direction
we can keep an open mind about that so
what does it do what are the what do
these deepest branches in the tree of
life do well they're bacterial-like
things archaea and bacteria
and they're pretty much autotrophic
which means that they are converting
gases in the environment into organic
molecules like photosynthesis except
probably not photosynthesis
um and they're almost universally
starting with co2 and hydrogen
and that's the very core of biochemistry
you go you react co2 and hydrogen and
you get krebs cycle intermediates that's
that's the first things that you get and
from there you get amino acids and from
there you get nucleotides and so on
the problem is that hydrogen and co2
don't react very easily this is the
problem that the chemists had for a long
time you can heat them up you can add a
catalyst it's you know it it does work
but it's uh it's difficult it's only
been in the last few years that people
have succeeded in doing it now what life
does
is it uses effectively an electrical
charge on the membrane around the cell
to drive that reaction
um the problem is it's it's
thermodynamically favored which is to
say if you've got a mixture of hydrogen
and co2 and you mix them up at say 50
degrees centigrade thermodynamically you
should get cells it's actually more
stable to have cells than it is to have
a disequilibrium of hydrogen and co2
they want to react so long as there's no
oxygen around
but kinetically there's a barrier and
they don't react
um and that kinetic barrier is broken
down by by this electrical charge on the
membrane
sorry just to clarify when you say you
get cells you don't mean cells as we
know it as life you mean that there's a
membrane and it's oily and then there's
a separation or
i i mean that um
if you look at the thermodynamics
theoretical thermodynamics that goes
back to jan ammond and tom mccollum and
they have considered under the kind of
conditions that i'm thinking about this
is 20 years ago now
under the kind of conditions that i'm
talking about in alkaline hydrothermal
vents at 50 degrees centigrade in
alkaline conditions
um energy is released
um
to make amino acids and fatty acids
and overall total cell biomass
releases energy from hydrogen co2
so yes it's favored it's it's actually
energetically
more favored to have literally cells
than it is to have a mixture of gases
that's what's driving life the problem
is that there's a barrier to it
happening and that barrier is broken
down by this electrical charge on
membrane so my kind of driving question
is
where did that come from
how did it get going
why do you think it is that there's so
much disagreement about the definition
of life so in mathematics you just
simply state the definition there's no
squabbling over that ah but have you
come up with the definition of life in
mathematics i mean the answer is no
um
it's basically it's not
it's not easy to put it into an equation
i think that's
i i i personally think the is the wrong
question because
life is a process over time it's it's
not a thing
um
and the origin of life is is not a
moment it's not
there isn't one moment where something
becomes alive it's a continuum from
prebiotic chemistry right the way up to
you know quite sophisticated cells with
genes and macromolecular machines motors
and what have you um and every step
along that way there isn't one moment
where you would say it's now alive
there's suddenly something goes like
that
and you know you can you could argue
about is a virus alive or not i would
say it is but it doesn't have a
metabolism of its own and it wouldn't
fall within most definitions of life
what about jumping jeans retro elements
these kind of things are they alive what
about something which is dormant to
spore in in deep space is it alive no
it's not living now but it could come
back to life so there's all these
ambiguities about
i i think what is living is a much
better question
and you know it's very easy to kind of
wave your arms and say well it needs
metabolism in these information in these
compartmentalization those things are
probably true um
but
but more than that you know you can any
definition that you come up with of life
can usually be attacked the the classic
one is uh from
is is known as the the working
definition of life
from nasa
and i probably can't get this quite
right but it's roughly a
self-sustaining
system capable of making copies of
itself or capable of evolving or
something along those lines
um and i have a real problem with the
word self-sustaining because it's
basically sustained by the environment
by disequilibrium in them in the
environment but you know people have
poked fun at it by saying well by that
definition a rabbit is not alive only a
pair of rabbits would be alive because
only a pair of rabbits could make a copy
right right right
okay so there's some arbitrariness to it
because it's akin to saying when does a
grain of sand become a heap by adding
more and more greens okay yes so then it
would be better to characterize it as a
real number rather than zero or one
uh it's certainly not binary yes i mean
you might even say that death looks
binary doesn't it but it's even death is
not because
when we die some of our cells will stay
alive for a while longer it feels binary
and therefore the origin of life perhaps
feels binary for exactly the opposite
reasons you know you wonder about when
when does it when when does a
when does life begin in in humans
there's terrible arguments about that
kind of question and there isn't really
a correct answer to it either
you know if
sperm are alive in some sense but but
and a fertilized
egg is is alive but it's not really
aware of very much but you know where do
you draw
a line of where awareness comes in it's
it's basically an impossible ask and
it's it's a matter of for people to try
and come to an agreement about but it's
there isn't a definition
so a better question may be
when is living or what is living
i remember you said living the word
living versus yes yes i mean living is
an active process over time and it's
it's it's a continuous reaction that is
converting
um the environment into in one way or
another more of itself whether that more
of itself is just replace the broken
bits or if it's a case of make a copy of
the whole cell
um
or or
or or or fuse with another cell and go
through some complicated process of of
sex and so on but in the end
life is effectively parasitizing the
environment to make copies of itself
and it does that through
metabolism okay so two thoughts occur to
me so one is is there a way to put a
number like i mentioned a real number
but perhaps it's not as simple as that
is there a way to place a number to how
much something is characterized by
living in the same way that you may say
well consciousness is either you either
have it or don't but then there's some
theories like tononi's integrated
information theory where you have phi
which is like okay if you have a large
number okay so that's the first thought
and then i'll say the second one then
i'll come back to them just so that i
don't forget them then the second
thought was how far can we generalize
this is so-and-so living
because in the self-development world
when you read you walk by the sections
in the library they'll say yeah you're
alive but you're not
living your purpose uh well that's
that's kind of
that's playing with semantics okay so
that's taking it too far okay okay so
let's focus on the first one is there a
way i mean i'm using living in the in
the in the in the broadest possible
sense
um in the sense of alive as well
uh so so but you know
consciousness you know if you look at
the medical literature there's all kinds
of gradations of conscious states
whether you're fully anesthetized or
fully unconscious or in some lower level
of consciousness and so on and it's you
know it it's it's worth looking at that
medical literature every now and then to
realize that it's not an on or off
switch there either
yeah i'm super interested in speaking
with you about consciousness so we'll
get to that toward the end just so you
know i've been
just absorbing your work for the past
maybe two weeks or so every single day
and
i i have my own nick cycle so people
have krebs cycle have a knick cycle in
my brain
that sounds
sounds hard
[Laughter]
so i just you know my background isn't
math and physics yeah yeah yeah and i
don't like biology because there's so
many terms too many times
there's pyruvic acid which i assume so i
can only apologize about my book i mean
you know it's uh
it's basically a problem with biology
and physicists always have this problem
with biology
yeah and and you know it's
understandable
um
and
there are i think the the most
interesting questions in biology now
really of questions in physics
um but because we've had this almost
kind of phase
separation between physicists and
biologists
there's not enough people who are
biophysicists who are grappling with the
biophysics of life
and so biology has gone off in the
direction of information but without
really a very serious grounding in
information theory as a physicist
understand it uh it's really about you
know just just
let's sequence the hell out of
everything and see if we can find a
pattern um and that's kind of
intellectually very shallow there are
patterns there and we've learned
you know almost everything about the
world from doing that
but it doesn't really tell us you know
your question what is life and what is
living and those things
the answer is not to be found in in
sequencing all the organisms you know
you have to take a step back and think
about well what is metabolism and what
are genes and which came first and how
do they relate to each other
uh and what processes on the planet are
driving this whole process and these are
often questions in physics
um but biology is so intrinsically
complex
that physicists very often
get pissed off and back away and you
know
they can't deal with too much pyruvate
yeah there's a flurry of unmitigated
polysyllabic terminology that it's
difficult to become acquainted with like
it's a moral i the way that i imagine is
that you become used to it over time and
so if you first encounter it then it's
overwhelming at least for me but you and
michael evan are responsible for turn in
toe in this channel toward more
to interviewing more biology michael
levin is doing amazing work and and
you know all this
electrical fields controlling
development
is
most biologists at the moment if you say
that to them would probably freak out
probably back i don't know what he said
to you about this but um you know he he
he's obviously right he's obviously
found something which is really
important um you know his nobel prize
winning stuff he that he's doing in my
opinion um
and and it's profound and this is the
direction of 21st century biology um and
and you you know it's trying to
understand what what actually is this
language of fields in cells you know
it's early days in terms of that but
most biologists still now would would um
back away from it
and
treat it in some way as pseudoscience or
as
you know just not real
um
and yet there's you know there's corners
of zoology which deal with with you know
electric eels and electric fields in
fish or
magnetic fields in in navigation systems
in birds and insects and whatever else
you know biologists have known about
this stuff for a while not necessarily
the development pathways but
it's some marginalized small corner
where of a field of information in terms
of gene sequences is completely dominant
and genes don't tell you anything about
shape about structure you can look at
any genome you want
and nobody unless they already knew what
the organism was that's coded for there
would be able to tell you what shape it
is what kind of an organism is it
like i mentioned i have a nick cycle in
my head so
well i mean that in many ways because i
started bicycling more just to get your
audio back in the head so cycling is a
great word certain words that you say
strike me because your book is in my
working memory currently and you said
20th century biology is going to be the
biology sorry 21st century biologically
the biology of fields okay why don't we
expand on that
um
so so that was right at the end of the
book uh we're talking about
consciousness really um but but also
development and how
how cells know when to stop nowhere to
go no no no you know there's all kinds
of questions that michael levin talks
about
from my own point of view
um
i've been
thinking for a long time about
bioenergetics that's my own kind of
specialty
and what cells are doing in the
mitochondria is effectively pumping
protons across a membrane and generating
a charge on the membrane and that charge
on the membrane is is driving everything
else
um but i hadn't thought very much about
fields as such
um because to to generate coherent feels
you you um would need to have quite
quite specific morphology
um
and it's not something i really worried
about very much but if you look at
mitochondria under a microscope what
you'll often see is is is these
membranes which are parallel to each
other which are offset by the same
degree and you know there's there's a
very detailed structure there and the
more we know about these structures the
more we realize that they play a really
important role in how mitochondria and
energy works it's not a trivial thing
those membranes are arranged that way
for a reason and and and
and we realize now as well that the
the the the motors the atp synthase
they're dimers at the end of these
christie and all the rest of the
complexes are in the middle and so
you've got a circuit going on you've
basically got a
um an oscillating charge
um which is
going to produce a field and we've got
multiple parallel christian all lined up
next to each other and if they're
oscillating in phase then these fields
should be strengthened
um
you know now if talking in a language
where
you're much more comfortable than i am
but um
if you are able and you know things that
have happened in neurology relatively
recently if you if you cut
an axon for example and separate it by
up to about 40 micrometers uh an action
potential can still hop the gap
you know it's
we've known about the eeg for more than
a century um the electroencephalogram so
we know that the brain is basically
electrical but amazingly people don't
really know
where those charges coming from there's
an assumption which is that oh it's just
depolarizing neurons it's an action
potential going down this you know
there's a network of all these neurons
all
doing their thing hundreds of cells
maybe thousands of cells all firing
simultaneously or in a circuit order but
that's what we're picking up on
but do we actually know that i don't
think we do the the fields are quite
weak on the on the membrane itself but
inside the cells we've got all these
mitochondria with stacked christie
generating what ought to be quite
powerful fields um
which should interact with the fields on
the membranes as well directly and and
interfere with whether or not they're
sending a signal or not um and this is a
whole area of biology that you know the
moment is hand waving we don't know if
any of this is true and it makes a very
specific prediction about the
orientation of membranes if they're all
offset to each other then the fields
would interfere with each other and it
would never work so you know there's
quite specific requirements for this to
work
but
it's
it does seem to be oriented that way it
does seem to work that way and then then
you end up with really interesting
questions to me which is well
why
the mitochondria why these fiddly things
inside cells why not the level of neural
networks
and the reason for me there
goes goes back
actually i wrote a book 10 years ago 12
years ago called life ascending and
there's a chapter in there on
consciousness where i failed to answer
the question at all to my own
satisfaction at least well everyone does
you're uncomfortable comfortable uh well
i i
i was left with with two uncomfortable
conclusions one of them was that and
this i was really only reporting on what
other people said um one of them is that
it's property of physics it's a property
of matter it's an unknown
uh unknown property of matter and when
we know a bit more physics then we'll
understand what consciousness is and so
the sun is conscious in some
way or another it's pan psychism and
it's got a you know people like roger
penrose and and and hammer off and so on
have been arguing along these lines
uh for for for a long time
um
i find it
uncomfortable
um i don't really believe that the sun
or the moon is consciousness conscious
in a meaningful way i tend to think of
it as a well basically a property of a
nervous system
um
so but but if you think of it just as a
property of a nervous system
then then it comes down from from my
point of view as a biochemist you've got
a depolarizing neuron you've got you
you've got you've got sodium ions
rushing in
um potassium ions you know your ions are
changing around um and that gives rise
to a feeling
and if what's the feeling in physical
terms if it's not a property of matter
what actually is it more you know is it
simply
in that sense an illusion that's
concocted by a central nervous system
and i find that very unsatisfying as an
answer as well
and it also kind of says that
it's a property of central nervous
systems so what did selection act on and
this is where michael levin's ideas are
really important because he's saying
that no is much wider than that all
cells have these fields all cells are
communicating electrically it goes right
back to not just the earliest
animals but probably back to single
uh critters as well
and then when you start thinking about
well the charges in mitochondria are
inside cells well mitochondria were
bacteria once they were free living once
and so the charges that they have on
their membranes
is separating the inside of the
bacterial cell from the outside world
and so it has much more meaning you can
see you can understand why selection
would act on that it's effectively
telling you how am i doing in the world
right now am i am i about to die am i is
something gone wrong is you know it's a
real selective value that this is kind
of giving you an
integrated real-time feedback on your
state in the world as an electrical
field as integrates the whole cell
and when you start thinking in those
terms
and you start realizing that well
driving this reaction between co2 and
hydrogen at the origin of life requires
an electric
an electrical charge on a membrane
um and so electrically charged membranes
go right back to the beginning and it's
the only way really of integrating the
cell as an entity in relation to its
environment then there's a beautiful
idea there i'm not really saying that
bacteria are conscious in a meaningful
way it's just that
there are
kind of integrated states of their state
of being in the world either they're
doing well or they're stressed you know
that kind of level of
um
of feedback
it it it's calibrated by a field and
those fields are used during development
to say okay now you've grown enough now
stop now you're in a high or whatever it
may be and this is a whole language of
how fields are communicating in biology
which we've barely
touched the tip of the iceberg
okay let me see if i got the stream
so earlier we you mentioned that there's
an axon you can cut it and then you can
separate it such that
chemicals shouldn't be able to be
interchanged between here like
neurotransmitters too slow for that yes
so it'll just hop over as if there was
no gap
however there's still a signal that
signals called an action potential yep
okay
and one of the reasons you think or
people think mitochondria are important
are because you use this word christy
which i believe refers to the these are
the membranes inside
yes exactly
okay and the reason why these folds are
important is because they have plenty of
surface area even though they're small
yes they they have a lot of surface area
but they also have a structure and an
orientation they're lined up in parallel
very often
and and they they have a very high
charge
and ironically
it's very difficult to measure that
charge
um why because
because if you're measuring the charge
in a neuron
you can you can insert a microelectrode
into a neuron and it was all originally
it was all done uh with giant neurons in
squids and things like that um
but but still you can insert an
electrode into a neuron but remember a
mitochondrion is a small part of a cell
so it's much smaller than a neuron
um
and
and people have done this people have
inserted microelectrodes into
mitochondria
and the irony is they've never really
measured much of a potential difference
and the reason for that is almost
certainly that what they they've just
inserted it into what's called a matrix
which is the main kind of bulk space
inside the mitochondrion and so they're
measuring a difference between that and
the rest of the cell
and it's not much but then you've got
these structures that christie which are
very tight membranes which is basically
impossible to poke a needle into
and that's where all the charges so to
try and measure that charge is a really
difficult thing to do
uh and people are getting closer to it
now there's some really clever ingenious
ways of trying to measure what exactly
is the charge in this closed space
really narrow closed space
um
but it you know it's it's it's a very
difficult technical problem you can cut
you can basically calculate it you can
show it with dyes but you never really
know what the dyes are interacting with
otherwise so it's it's intrinsically
difficult uh okay do you imagine that
this is a technological problem that
will be solved in the near future i hope
or there's some in principle reason why
it can't be done
uh no i think um i i mean it's just
difficult but i think we can do it i
mean i intend to give it my own best
shot but there's a few other people
thinking along these lines as well
now the fact that mitochondria may be
important for consciousness does that
imply that the bacteria which don't have
mitochondria are not conscious or at a
much lower level of consciousness than
protozoa
um so protozoa do have mitochondria
um and you know you can see videos of
the way that they behave and they're
astonishing i mean you know watch videos
of protozoa the way that they move
around and they they go fishing they do
all kinds
the control of their behavior is
exquisite um
it's the kind of thing that
you know should make people believe in
god it's just so beautiful
um so
it's not a matter of genes being
expressed there's something controlling
this system
uh which is
which is
happening in in nanoseconds is you know
it's happening extremely quickly and
it's it's the whole cell which is doing
this it's not just one bit of the cell
it's not you know
imagine you're a molecule
finish the book this way imagine that
you're a molly shrink yourself down to
the size of a molecule a cell is like a
city
um
where i am now i'm in london and
20 15 20 miles away uh through to canary
wharf or greenwich or somewhere like
that um
there would be other molecules you know
the people over there would be like me
as a molecule as a pyruvate molecule
inside a cell or something so what is it
that unites me
with this
person
20 miles away
in a cell and and the answer is well you
know
in the city not much some kind of shared
sense of identity as a londoner or
something but you know you know you you
know that you're living in a city but
that's conscious awareness but in a cell
while we're dealing with molecules
how does something happening over here
happen over there
simultaneously essentially
simultaneously effectively 20 miles away
so that we're integrated in in real time
and doing the same thing
now
fields can do that for sure so how would
you have a field that operates on the
whole cell if it's on the membrane that
surrounds the cell
and if what that membrane is reporting
on is how are you doing in relation to
the environment because if you you know
if you're if you're taking up food from
the environment and burning it and using
the energy to generate an electrical
charge on the membrane and there's
plenty of food you've got a nice charge
everything's good
um
so it's it's telling you that the the
whole cell has got a nice electrical
charge on the membrane there's a nice
field crossing the cell
oscillation so
water molecules within the cell are kind
of locking things in some kind of phase
and
and um
that is telling you about your state if
you move into an area where there's
toxins
or where there's no food or whatever it
may be then
then you're you're you know they're
going to interfere
with how this charge works it's going to
change the field and and you're going to
shift you're going to change what you do
you're going to move over there you're
going to set your your
your flagellum whirring or something
you you'll change your behavior but you
do it at the level of a whole cell
and what's integrating at the level of
the cell in my view now is is the the
charge on the membrane generating a
field which is integrating all the
component molecules in the cell to act
as a
as a unified hole
here's one question if we have one cell
and it's we imagine that it may have
some proto form of consciousness because
it's interacting with the outside okay
and then if we have two and they're
interacting with one another then we
have a consciousness that is of the two
as a whole
um not necessarily uh if they're in if
they're locked in phase in some way as
they may be if with two neurons locked
in phase in a multicellular organism
um then yes they could be but if they're
not in phase then then they
would interfere with each other in some
way there's actually lots of evidence
that for example
um pollinating insects when they arrive
on a flower can sense electrically
whether or not it's already
whether the nectar is already being
taken so they don't bother to go there
you know there's an interference that i
don't know very much about
um but
you know there's quite a lot of evidence
that the animals have fields that are
capable of interacting with each other
we just don't know a huge amount about
it and the idea that cells would do the
same thing i mean you can see it under
the microscope we don't know exactly
what's going on i don't think we've ever
measured it
but i'm fairly
fairly persuaded that fields would be
one of the most powerful ways of trying
to explain the interactions you see
between single cells yes
now this locked in phase quality i
imagine is also
a spectrum and not zero to not binary or
is it i know well
you tell me you're the physicist i mean
i i would imagine that there's something
of a spectrum but but there's some
element in which once you get
interference then you don't have you
would not have any locked in place
what i'm thinking is that
i'm imagining the brain akin to those
vertices of there's points there's
vertices and then there's edges between
them and then there's a slew of them and
then they're interacting with one
another and that any subset of these
not any subset but there will be
manifold subsets so plenty not manifold
in the math sense but man many many
subsets that will be in phase with one
another any given point in time and so
any individual
comprises
perhaps more conscious
subsets than there are atoms in the
universe if you do some analysis of how
many subsets and so on that is to say
that nick is not just one consciousness
it would be trillions if or 10 to the
trillions
well but i don't know so because i don't
know what counts as consciousness here
yeah i mean i'm not i'm not a
neurologist and i'm not working on
consciousness as we know it in human
brains
um
what bothered me
um
you know it's a question in philosophy
as well is is is is if you've got an and
it touches on ai and whatever else if
you've got an extremely sophisticated
processing system
um
and the brain is an extremely
sophisticated processing system uh
does it need to be conscious is there
some kind of emergence
and if so what governs that emergence
um and it may be that that is the case
but
i'm i i find emergence one of those
words which is overused it has a real
meaning but it's very easy to say oh
it's an emergent property and you know
it's basically it says i have no clue
what i'm talking about it's just a nice
word um
so
so i had this problem
i i can imagine
the classical philosopher's zombie which
is capable of behaving in a perfectly
normal human way without experiencing
any emotions or any feelings or anything
else and i can imagine robots and an ai
uh being like that as well capable of
being enormously intelligent and and
having you know conversations that would
persuade us that they are human um but
without feeling anything um
and so i'm background to this question
of well what is a feeling is it real is
it a is it a concoction of a central
nervous system an emergent property what
actually is it
and to my mind
um
natural selection always works on
something else there are simpler systems
so you know it it
so i'm perfectly happy to believe that a
dog for example
is not necessarily
that intelligent i don't know but i i i
would think it's consciously aware
and and and capable of feelings capable
of emotions and the idea that a dog will
pine after its masters died or whatever
is you know it's very familiar to most
people and and it seems
obvious to me
um that that would be the case and from
a biologist point of view why would it
not be the case selection has to act on
something why would one central nervous
system be utterly different to another
one there's a matter of it's a continuum
again we have a really
high power processing system but our
feelings our emotions
you know i i think we probably share
them with a lot of other creatures and
it's very easy to imagine that the the
you know chimpanzee can be in love or
can feel pain or or any of these
feelings
they feel
animalistic to me
and we can nuance them with with all
kinds of
intelligence and thoughts and language
and whatever else but the you know a
feeling of of malignant sadness
underneath everything else is it's it's
it's not something which is
you that you have much control over
or a feeling of just being
overwhelmingly in love with someone what
what what can you do you know we have no
control over these these feelings
they're they're very
separate almost from from a parallel
processing system they can be
overwhelming um and so
so what what what are they and this is
where i think this language of feels and
so on comes in and i'm not saying that a
bacterium is conscious in a way that any
of us would recognize i'm just saying
it's the germ of a kind of a
something which tells you about your
state and which is not just it's more
than the sum of all of these parts it's
something which gives you an integrated
feedback on
am i am i effectively sad or happy you
might say i'm am i content in this
environment or am i stressed in this
environment that's the nature of a
feeling
okay so to be clear you're not claiming
that this solves the heart problem of
consciousness but rather if
consciousness was to have some physical
explanation perhaps we should look at
the what's occurring at the cell
membrane electrically
uh well the the membranes inside in the
mitochondria and so on yes i think
that's the language i think that
provides a selective basis for how it
began
i think it's it you know this question
about what purpose is consciousness in
in in natural selection
if you think about it at the level of
single cells if you think that it's
giving you this real time integrated
feedback on your state in the world
and whether or not you make a decision
as a cell to go over there or to stay
here or to depolarize your membrane and
kill yourself immediately if you've been
infected by a virus or all of these kind
of decisions that you take as an entity
um this is providing you with a kind of
language for the entity
and it you immediately see what
selection is acting on and the hard
problem in consciousness is
to a large extent about what what our
feelings what our emotions in in in
physical terms
uh and and that's
you know people have been talking about
electrical fields for quite a long time
in that sense as well this is again
nothing particularly new but but why
that language
why why would electrical fields give you
some kind of feeling of being conscious
when you take it out of the environment
of a nervous system and put it into the
environment of single cells and this
real-time feedback
on their environment their state in
their environment then you you see it's
the only language which is going to
integrate you as a unit which is going
to tell
tell the other half of the cell 20 miles
away over there that that uh
is that it's an er you know your action
is for the whole cell
and so when you put two cells together
and and you build multicellular
organisms you're using these fields to
control the development of the organisms
as as michael levin says and then as you
end up with a central nervous system
it's channeling more of that energy into
circuits and you know
whatever the explanation is it has to
correspond to what we already know about
neurology about the way that neural
networks actually work and the problem i
have for example with
with um
with penrose and hammer off and the idea
that it's it's all
uh to do with um with microtubules for
example is that it's not
very obvious
how they correspond to at least it's not
to me how they correspond to what we
already know about neurology about
neural networks and so on whereas
mitochondria are completely integrated
into that
um they're part of the neurons they're
part of
uh the depolarization of neurons they
can interfere with this electric
electrically and so on so they're
they're they're linked in
with the structure i think of the
neurons in a different in a different
way
the reason though that i
came back to this and and started taking
it seriously
um and you know lots of people seem to
think that i'm barking up the wrong tree
altogether and should never talk about
neurology again or consciousness again
um but the the the reason is is is an
interaction with a biophysicist called
luca turin
and and he came to see me a few years
ago and
was talking about anesthetics general
anesthetics we don't really know how
they work
um and
and and he he was interested in xenon in
particular which is an inert gas
and
that it doesn't really have a shape it's
a sphere of electron density so it's not
obviously going to interact with any
type of receptor
and all the different general
anaesthetics they have different shapes
and different different chemical
properties and it's not obvious that
there's any kind of
type of receptor that would deal with
them all
and and it doesn't really have any
chemistry but it can
uh transfer electrons and so it can
interfere
with electron transfer and what luca
turin had shown which really made me
excited is is is that
they do interfere with the transfer of
electrons to oxygen
in respiration now that doesn't prove
it's causal that just shows that
anesthetics
interfere in some way with respiration
and maybe if they simply suppress what
the rest of the cell is doing that would
have a knock-on effect on respiration
you could you could say that that would
be the case
but they he didn't find anything else
that
a general anaesthetic was having an
effect on
and so if you put it together with what
i was saying about
the requirement for cells and the
electrical charge on the membranes to
integrate
their state in the environment
then suddenly
it it's a rather thrilling idea
um
doug wallace is another person who's
been working on these fields in
mitochondria for some time now uh and
and again is
he's out there on a limb as far as
biology is concerned he's he's one of
the few people who's willing to
to talk about parallel christie
generating strong electromagnetic fields
that are reinforcing each other and
communicating
across distances this is not
this is not the language that biology is
used to and and you know doug wallace is
is very distinguished and so people will
kind of
tolerate him uh towards the end of his
career talking about these things
luca turin is is uh
i won't say he's an outcast but he you
know he's he's on the edge of
scientific respectability and he's not
because he's not a good he's a brilliant
scientist it's just that he's saying
things that people in biology don't want
to hear
interesting
turin has found that xenon interrupts or
interferes with respiration and when you
say respiration you mean cellular
respiration with the transfer of
electrons yes which is to say this is
what's going on in mitochondria the the
so you basically have a the current of
electrons going from food to oxygen
um and
and gases like xenon interfere with that
uh that that uh current of electrons and
that means that it makes respiration
less likely to occur and by the way what
is cellular respiration i assume you've
taken oxygen but um i don't know if that
analogy between my respiration yeah yeah
i mean basically you're yes no it's
exactly right i mean you're we're
stripping electrons from food
by the krebs cycle that's what the krebs
cycle is doing is taking electrons from
food it's feeding them into the membrane
and then we have a current of electrons
in the membrane going to oxygen oxygen
picks up two electrons and two protons
um and and
and
it
it ends up as water
and and that and so so basically we
we're reacting hydrogen
the electrons and the protons we're
taking we're taking hydrogen from food
we're reacting with oxygen but we're not
doing it in one step that's rocket fuel
you know that's what's that's what's
powering a rocket um
we've basically got a current from one
to the other and that that current is
powering
the extrusion of protons across the
membrane and that's what's putting the
electrical charge on the membrane so now
we have an electrical charge on the
membrane and the orientation of these
christie structures
it means that this is a current of
protons it's an oscillating current of
protons and that's what's generating the
field is there a radio wave associated
with this
with turin found that somehow
okay
there there is yes
um i don't i have to say i don't quite
understand that please explain the
significance of this
um
well there's a funny story that he tells
about that um because the guy who uh i
forget his name now the guy who
discovered the eeg in the first place
the electro encephalogram michael cohen
or no no that's different no no this
goes back much before this goes i just
have different snippets of this book in
my head i remember michael cohen said
something like no one understands but he
no we're going we're going back 100
years or more uh to the to the discovery
that the brain is generating electrical
signals it can be detected with
electrodes on the scalp he was actually
looking for radio waves
he was looking for long distance
communications between people i think he
had
um
he'd had some premonition that terrible
accident had befallen his sister or
something and i i it turned out you know
lots of people have these premonitions
that something terrible has happened to
a friend
i have them as well and every time i
have them it never turns out to be true
but you know for some people it's it's
true
is it true
is it true because it's real or is it
true because statistically is going to
be true sometimes i i don't know i've
never looked exactly
um but but
that's what he was interested in that's
what he was looking for communication by
radio waves between people at a distance
of maybe hundreds of miles um and he
discovered the eeg instead
um and and it's ironic because
the key
we're on your ground again here more
more than my ground but um there's
there's a there's a an israeli scientist
who's shown that
electrons spin
if it's passing through a chiral medium
um ends up in in in the same spin state
so it's been polarized um
and a chiral medium includes proteins
because proteins are made of amino acids
and amino acids are always in the in in
in the left-handed form
um
and and so all the the the the current
of electrons that flows from hydrogen to
oxygen goes through proteins in this
membrane and those proteins are chiral
and that means that the
um the the the electrons that are
transferred are actually locked in the
same spin state
and and when you lose that spin state
that emits a radio signal and that's
what luca turin has detected
you mentioned something interesting
which is that there's apparently a
psychic phenomenon unverified or maybe
it has been but we don't know as far as
i know it's unverified well people
believe they can communicate to one
another one of the reasons why on
theories of everything i don't mind
talking to some people who believe
they've done studies and they're
excluded from academia for whatever
reason i want to find out the validity
of those because i think that there may
be something to with certain
aspects of what people consider to be
paranormal that their explanation for
why it works may be incorrect there may
be some physical basis like it's that we
we're obviously communicating right now
we don't think that there's any psychic
abilities involved because we're just
going through the computer but perhaps
something similar where radio waves are
being transmitted and if it's of a
strong enough distress then perhaps the
person feels it i think that science is
intrinsically very conservative
and there was a lovely phrase from peter
meadow who said science is the art of
the soluble which is to say
problems that we can actually solve
so problems that we can't solve because
we don't know how to go about it we tend
to put to one side and reject is not
science
um
and that goes for all kinds of things um
including esp and so on um now
i i to my mind there's two questions
number one is is
it real and then number two is well can
we
then explain it
and
i don't think very many scientists get
involved in the question of is it real
um it's it's just not part of what
science asks because it's not
there isn't that we don't have a
a
a way of answering it
um
really so we don't ask it
and now
so it may be real or may not be real i i
don't know
i think there's another
factor though which is that
occam's razor which underpins all of
science really which says don't don't
multiply causes try and find the
simplest the simplest explanation that
explains everything we need to know
it may or may not actually be true
but but it is what governs science which
is to say you first of all take the
simplest
simplest possibility and and test that
and if it doesn't work then try the next
simplest one and work your way up until
you end up with something mad but um
but the problem with with with anything
like esp is it's almost certainly not
the simplest explanation for things now
if someone were to show that it's real
and that it really is happening and and
you know statistically in some kind of
trial
it would have to be with the power of a
clinical trial and then it's going to
cost a lot of money and it's going to
you know there were so many comebacks
from people who are determined to
demonstrate that it's not true
that it would be
a very very difficult thing to do
um and
then it boils down to personal
experience i i've never really
you know i don't really believe in
ghosts because i've never seen one or i
don't see any reason why they would
exist and i've never had any experience
with them but perhaps if i did then i
would change my mind i don't really
believe in esp because i have these
feelings that other people have that
says something terrible has happened but
then that phone them up and nothing
nothing had happened it was just
my imagination terrible happened to you
yeah well you know
there's a simpler explanation which is
just that my brain is active
um right so
you know you're thinking about someone
so so
and probably for most people most of the
time that's the real answer so i you
know i
i'm skeptical of these things
um
but there's a whole lot more out there
than than we know now and i've been
talking about fields and consciousness
and so on
and that is already pushing the barrel
out for most biologists in terms of what
are we willing to accept now i think
there's very strong grounds there for
accepting those kind of things and we
can begin to push it into looking at
other languages and genes
um
but
if i then start spouting on about esp or
something then then then you know i'll
be cold-shouldered by the entire
community and i have no desire to go
down that path because i have no strong
reason to think that there is that
exists anyway
okay i don't have a question but i have
a some thoughts so then i can just state
them and then hear what your response is
to them so number one when it comes to
occam's razor i always find that a bit
tricky unless someone's speaking about
something in physical law something
mathematical occam's razor it's unclear
to me what constitutes as an assumption
so for example in physics the way that
you say that
a certain model is simpler is that you
use less parameters to specify it so
it's actually quantifiable how simple a
model is and that's one of the reasons
why people say string theory is the most
beautiful because it can supposedly
reduce it all down to one parameter it's
still one parameter like there's no you
have there's still some freedom there
but it's one as opposed to 26 or so
and then so let's say the principle of
induction in science is that one
assumption or is that two assumptions or
three assumptions because it presumes
there exists a future in the past and
then i'm sure you've heard of the
problem of induction the point is
if it's not mathematically stated then
to me because my brain is so analytical
it's difficult to see well what's being
assumed and what's not like is god the
simplest assumption well then god has
the trouble of explaining like you can't
predict from that but god certainly is
the most simple well
yes i mean it depends what um but then
it's not simply simplicity is god five
assumptions
yeah well i mean
as soon as you start wondering
where god came from
you know what what gave rise to god in
the first place there's a lot of
assumptions behind that so something as
as profound and all encompassing as god
it requires in some way an awful lot of
assumptions behind it but then you know
we know a lot about the world as well we
don't understand it all
but you know it's it's definitely four
and a half billion years old there's
definitely signs of bacteria from four
billion years ago there was definitely
stasis for about two billion years there
was definitely oxygen appearing
around 2 billion years ago
there were definitely more complex cells
appearing after that we animals
certainly appeared around the time of
the cambrian explosion 540 50 million
years ago um
and and so you know any assumption that
god did it would require either a deist
god that set it in motion at the
beginning and then it follows its own
path or a god that's kind of involved
all the way along with every little bit
here and there and there's no
there's no need for that as voltaire
said there's no requirement to for for
god to
kind of get involved in this this
species of bacteria
differentiating from that speech you
know
that's the level of detail he would have
to be involved in
so so there's no need for that
hypothesis
deism
um i think will be very difficult to
reject for most scientists who had an
open mind
um but deism i don't think is something
that most people who are religious
would be terribly happy about because i
think for most people god is
communicating with them personally in in
one way or another so the idea that
there's an aloof god somewhere at the
other end of the universe that sets
everything sets the laws of physics in
motion and then steps back and is never
seen again is not much of a comforting
figure for for most people but but
frankly
what we know about the world
if it's consistent with any form of god
is is more consistent with the deist
form of god i would say than anything
else um so then there are assumptions
and science works on these assumptions
and they may or may not be the simplest
ones but they underpin everything and
one of them is that um it's naturalistic
that it's not miracles that's not
science that's an assumption we assume
that
um
the that life started
uh and and and that we can understand
the principles that govern the origin of
life and and the evolution of life and
so on
it may be that there were miracles it
may be that it was delivered from outer
space there's all kinds of things that
could have happened
but we make a simplifying assumption
that it happened here on earth and it
happened for naturalistic reasons and
therefore we don't call on a miracle and
that we can understand those
naturalistic reasons these are three
huge assumptions
that may not be true there's nothing
scientific about them but all of science
is built on those ideas and and
the reason that i believe it to be true
and and most scientists would is that
well everything we know about the world
is consistent with that idea so
everything i was saying earlier on about
um you start with carbon dioxide and
hydrogen and you get krebs cycle
intermediates and you have electrical
charges on barriers in these
hydrothermal vel all of this is
is consistent
with the naturalistic origin of life
it's a long long way from proving that
that's what happened
but everything i know about it is
consistent with it sufficiently that i
have some faith
and i'm using the word deliberately
faith that
the gaps
between the bits that i know a little
bit about and and this long spectrum of
things that i don't know much about can
be filled in
in due course if we keep on thinking
constructively in that way so i think
you know science is always based on
assumptions and it's always
based on some form of faith which most
scientists are very reluctant to use the
word faith because in a religious sense
faith very often means belief in
something which
which is uh
you know irrational in some way that
it goes against the evidence
whereas in science faith is perhaps more
about i have faith that there'll be more
of this kind of evidence that will
explain the way that the world is it's a
form of faith
it may or may not be true it may be
delusional but it's very powerful
because it's led to all these scientific
advances that we see in the world and
that leads people and most people to
to begin to believe that
science really can explain the world and
there really isn't
a need for a god to explain the world
unless it be a deist god that put these
principles
in place in the first place
and that you know
that's the way i would see it but i have
a lot of sympathy with people who prefer
a religious view of the world there are
and i and and i certainly couldn't argue
against the deist's position
i wouldn't say that it's a minority the
deus position well when i say minority i
mean it's a sizable minority if it
exists because when i was looking at the
pew research data on belief i believe
something like 10 to 20 to 30 let's say
10 to 30 percent of people believe in a
deist god of those who say that they
believe in god that's sizeable because i
thought it would be 0.02
like the gnostics or something yes
i would expect it to be smaller as well
yeah it's an extreme amount and then
secondly that
there's a sizable portion of people who
believe that
the definition of god is reality so by
doing science one is studying god and
it's not so i used to be the son and i i
i love that as an idea i have to say i
don't i don't personally believe in god
but but but the idea
that you know people who have tried to
understand the world in the past as as
the world
that god put there
i have a huge fellow feeling with them
that you know they they were trying to
understand the world they were trying in
some way to understand the mind of god
um it's
what is nobler in this world and trying
to understand
these things and whether or not you put
the word god at the end of it
it seems to me almost a trivial
distinction
i remember my grandma saying to me
years and years ago that uh to her god
was the voice in her head that told her
what was right or what was wrong it was
basically her conscience and i remember
saying to her well i have a voice in my
head that tells me what's right and
what's wrong and i don't think that it's
god and she was shocked and horrified
that
that uh effectively i was saying i don't
believe in god and and it hurt her
deeply
and and i've never quite forgiven myself
and and you know i'm very careful
to try not to offend people because to
me it's
it's not very far away it's uh it's just
ways of phrasing things ways of seeing
things and there's no need to be
deliberately offensive to people when
actually we we may both see the glory of
the world and want to understand it
okay let me get philosophical here for a
moment
i think that was about as philosophical
as i can get
i may not stick when it comes to this so
i'm not coming at this from a religious
perspective just so you know so you can
feel safe to to surmise in any direction
what basis so your mother sorry your
grandmother had a basis to believe in
the
in the
to follow her conscience if you don't
believe that comes from some higher
place what does hire mean who knows
for the sake of this let's just put that
aside and assume that we can intuit that
then why should you follow your
conscience
um because our conscience has evolved in
the context of society of human
societies of groups of human groups
um
to my mind at least you know there's all
this
um interesting questions about human
evolution
when and why did we
develop in the way that we did when did
the human mind
take on the ability to be creative to do
art to believe in gods and and what have
you
the things that we think of as human
um
and it's not obviously to do with tool
use for example they often you know the
use of of uh flints and things and
spearheads goes back
um
you know hundreds of thousands of years
if not more than that um
and didn't change very much over a long
time and and things like fire it's a
little difficult to know exactly when
was fire invented and language is
another thing that we tend to as soon as
we've got language then then we develop
our minds in some way the one thing that
it seems to correlate with most
interestingly
is population density
this is work uh that that i i know of
from mark thomas um who's a colleague at
ucl
um
and that corresponds to human migrations
it corresponds to climate change all
kinds of things that we're
very familiar with now but if you have
multiple groups of people that are
interacting with each other regularly
whether it be through warfare or whether
it be you know much more
congenial interactions
um
those interactions are forcing
creativity and ingenuity and you know
sense of loyalty or tribalism or
whatever it may be
and right and wrong it can hardly help
but you know it has to emerge in that
kind of an environment
and it has to be very conflicted
you know
surely anybody knows that the people in
the tribe over there that you've been
brought up to hate are human beings too
and have you know have everything that
you have
why do you hate them because your
tribe brought you up in some way
you know
we are horribly conflicted and
our sense of right and wrong
comes from this kind of conflicted
feeling of fellow humans and loyalty to
groups and whatever else and no wonder
we can't agree about it it's uh you know
it's it's grounded very deeply in
in our emotions as individuals in the
social context
let me stay on this philosophical course
for just a few moments longer so firstly
this assumption which i believe is a
great assumption but it's i do believe
it to be an assumption that we're all
human the reason why i say that is that
while human biologically yes but human
also has a connotation of you being
worth a certain amount and having
dignity afford it to you and your rights
the same as mine that's fairly fairly
new genghis khan for example well many
if you just go back 1 000 years or 2 000
or 3000 years human is my tribe you're
not human you're inhuman you're
sub-human
yeah yeah i mean i don't know enough
history
to comment on that um
i i i mean i find it hard to believe
that
that we could ever really have felt that
way
um it seems
i mean you know culture and society will
tell us that there are differences
between people and racism and everything
else
you know
sustained human history but but but it's
it's kind of obvious and we know now you
know genetically and scientifically that
there are essentially we're amazingly
similar to each other as humans um we we
we we're
evolutionarily very closely related to
each other we've diverged very recently
and we have all of these systems
for
you know categorizing people and i'm
part of it in the sense that i work in
the university and i you know mark exams
and things like that and i'm very
conflicted over exams because they they
they they mark a certain type of
intelligence
and they give credit to and you know
there's so many different types of
intelligence that we're not adept at
categorizing
and very often to my mind the people who
are
the best researchers
they're not necessarily the people who
do best in exams they're the people who
who think about things in their own way
and who are obsessive about the question
and who who who
keep on pondering it and don't give up
very often and there are you know there
are some effortlessly brilliant people
but there are also you know darwin
himself was probably
not necessarily the sharpest cookie in
the basket but he he he asked and kept
on asking these questions and
and and and and ended up coming up with
answers that were more important than
anybody else's is different forms of
intelligence and you know
western
civilization western culture has tried
over over over centuries to
to categorize and to have a hierarchy
and to put the white man at the top of
the hierarchy and it's so patently not
true um the the it's shocking that it
ever stuck
okay so then here's some more thoughts
again a few questions but just thoughts
and then we'll get back to some well
these are biological questions so we're
saying that hey humans are so related to
one another and so it's difficult for
you to imagine that other people would
think of other people's not being human
but then to me i was like okay well we
have another spectrum issue there
because it's arbitrary where we define
the line as being sufficiently different
enough to not call human and then
secondly it's unclear as to what makes
you you is it purely your dna but or is
it also the culture and the ideas that
you
of course it's that culture and the
ideas and then if so well then what we
can say is this tribe has a right to say
that you are sufficiently different than
me unless you convert to me
uh i mean this is the nature of human
history isn't it it is tribalism and it
is it is
generating a sense of difference
um i mean you could almost say that
culture has has gone out of its way to
erect differences where they don't exist
um
you know i think individuals will always
if if two people from any culture
anywhere in the world are left as the
only two people left on the world and
are forced to talk to each other they
will realize they have everything in
common with each other and you know it's
it was true for practically anybody on
earth now
um and always has been but this you know
this idea of human or non-human or you
know
biology is so full of continua
um was the neanderthal of human
being
you know there was plenty in common i'm
sure there are gradations everywhere and
there isn't a there isn't a cutoff point
okay so then the last and i'll stop this
digression the last point is that if we
agree that tribalism is natural and is
almost a universal
then what if one's conscience
led them in the direction of saying hey
in order for my genes to survive it's
better than my group compete with your
group and my conscience is telling me so
so this gets back to the question
because i was asking yes well why follow
your conscience and you're saying well
because it developed evolutionarily well
what i'm saying is i can imagine it
yes yes in other words you're saying
it's wrong it grew up in the context of
tribalism
uh and antagonism between different
groups of people therefore and i said
you know the sense of right and wrong is
deeply conflicted and i'm probably not a
good guide to things
one of the i think one of the great
things about
um
as i i suppose
the the history
of
the uh from from the renaissance onwards
is is attempt to break down
some of these barriers
um to to to think in broad terms about
what human rights are and what what
what's
what are humans you know it's been a
very
you know it omitted women for a long
time and i've missed different groups
for a long time but but it was an
attempt
to
to begin to give people rights and see
people as
as equal
and this idea that we're equal is
obviously again
we're not equal we're not equal
genetically we're all different
genetically we're all an equal almost by
definition that doesn't mean to say
someone's better than someone else is
different
now and we come from societal cultural
contexts which are different
and which condition you to think
differently about things and those are
breaking down and and thank god for that
we lose we lose things when they break
down you know we we we lose our
our our culture our tradition is that
you know people lose groups lose
languages
there's a loss to
seeing humanity as a single
unit a global
family if you like
there's there's all the all the cultural
histories that groups have which are
wonderful and often you know different
but but similar
um
they can be engulfed and they can be
lost and and it's in a way it's tragic
but at the same time if if what we do is
cling to the
the differences and the cultural things
that set you apart from everybody else
and and then look down on other groups i
don't think there's anything in the in
in biology that that says that that's
the case
um
so you know what we need is somewhere
in the middle where we where we we we
we're proud of our cultures we're proud
of our traditions but we somehow um
understand other groups as equally human
with equally
valid and important traditions that we
live side by side together one of the
lovely things about living in a place
like london is it's often called a
melting pot but you know different
cultures live side by side
i won't say happily but reasonably
happily
people from countries that are at war
elsewhere in the world will we'll rub
shoulders together in a place like
london and get along together okay and
and and maintain something of their
culture and their own sense of identity
and self-worth
without without hating everybody else
okay let's get back to the book this is
a great transition because you mentioned
we should it would be great if we
thought of ourselves as a part of a
larger whole in the beginning of the
book i recall there was an analogy made
between a city and a cell and saying
okay let's zoom out at a helicopter view
and look at a city and it looks akin to
a cell
perhaps a cell is well i think a cell is
well i don't know if that's true but it
doesn't look much like a cell but yes i
mean i was i was i was uh comparing it
because there's plainly there's
metabolism there's movement there's
there's all kinds of things happening in
the city yes and then there was a line
that said the cell is living potentially
the cell is living but
it's but obviously the city is not
something like that obviously i was
thinking is it is it obviously that the
city's not like what makes something
living is it just is it something that
this is obvious that the city is not its
own conscious being if if one of our
neurons has some proto-consciousness but
then the collection of them also have a
larger consciousness are we a part of a
larger consciousness or is it slow
transmission speed yeah what you're back
to there really is is consciousness an
emergent property of a sufficiently
complex system
uh and what i was arguing earlier on is
that it's not
um that it's it is a property of an
extremely complex central nervous system
but but what it wasn't an emergent
property from it it was it was something
which was an integral part of that
complex system from the very beginning
i was talking about the language of
electrical fields and cells and so on
and this is what has been has been
ramped up and so
the the very
um
complex feelings and so on that we have
now are effectively
they've been through a process of
natural selection they have real meaning
for us because they've really been
selected we really
do it really does matter
um if you're starving or if you're if
you're
if you're
dying of thirst or if you
are
you know in in love or whatever it may
be these feelings are real because
they've been through
essentially
uncountable generations where
they bore some resemblance to
what happened to you what
to people to animals to organisms
in their lives that if you
if you have this overwhelming
fear of something and you run away you
will do better if this overwhelming
sense of something
um has a selective value
and at the level of single cells it has
a selective value just in terms of
integrating the cell as a unit as
something which can physically go over
there rather than have this flagellum
firing that way and this one going and
under what you know what what integrates
this system
um
so so so you have a you have a system
which is capable of of a purpose if you
like to read too big a word into it um
and that
has been honed by selection and ends up
in a central nervous system but it's not
an emergent property it's something
which was built in from the very
beginning and has just been been kind of
raised as part of the edifice
now from the from that point of view a
city
you know it hasn't it hasn't been
through generations it hasn't given rise
directly to an offspring city it hasn't
competed it hasn't died you know
it doesn't it doesn't have any of these
biological mechanisms of selection so i
think any biologist and maybe we're very
limited here but any biologist would
immediately say a city's not alive as i
did any physicist would probably say
well hang on a minute do you are you
really so confident that you know what
life is that you can say that the city
is definitely not alive
um
and
that boils down you know i had a
subtitle of an earlier book was why is
life the way it is and
and the question to me is actually a
really serious question which is does it
have to be this way
is it or could it have been a different
way could we have fred hoyle's black
cloud could we could a city be alive can
uh
can can ai become alive
um
you know they're very interesting
difficult questions
um
and unless we understand
i think there's two ways of going about
it one would be to say oh you've got a
closed mind and you're you're you're
you're you're a biologist and you're
thinking about carbon and you're
thinking about cells and you know open
your mind and be
be
you know
open to other possibilities
yeah and and the other way of seeing it
is to say well i don't know does life
have to be these things we know the only
example of life we know is life here on
earth and we know that it's carbon-based
we know that it's cellular we know it
thrives in water um so did it have to be
that way or could it have taken a
different turn or could we you know if
we understand why life is carbon-based
then we can begin to say well life has
to be carbon-based or no it doesn't have
to be carbon-based or or some spectrum
in between um
and
this is where
physicists will very often
by temperament and by training split off
from biologists because physicists will
want to see
the universe
as
almost infinite possibilities with a
very small number of laws governing it
and a biologist will want to see
study the example that we have in front
of us
realize there are no laws but there are
some principles that guide us that you
know there are no laws in biology um and
so it's fuzzy and it's it's uh it's
immediately irritating for any
self-respecting physicist but that
doesn't mean to say that there isn't
something to understand from life on
earth as we know it and there's you know
the the origin of life field
has
in a strange way almost try to ignore
what life actually is
that we know about and and and and to my
mind
it it
if we were to find life on a thousand
different
planets throughout the
through
throughout the um
the milky way or something um
then just because carbon is so good at
the chemistry that it does because it's
so abundant it's one of the most
abundant
elements in the in the universe it it
it's really good at producing molecules
that are quite large water is also
extremely abundant and it does very
interesting things with organic
molecules you can have membranes that
are not soluble and you can have
proteins that are soluble you know
there's a wealth of possibilities there
so you you take into consideration the
abundance and how good it is at doing
this chemistry and then you think well
you know is there an important
distinction between an outside and an
inside do you need a compartment
and if if you're going to keep your
inside different to your outside
stuff has to come and go does that give
of size are there constraints on how
large something can be and how active it
can obviously there are you don't need
to really understand exactly what
governs those constraints but
plainly there's a difference between an
inside and outside and before you know
it you've argued that life is likely to
be carbon-based and likely to be
cellular and likely to be on a planet
with water and so on and maybe there are
other ways of doing it but 995 times out
of a thousand is going to be a bit like
this
so let's talk about life on other
planets potential life an interesting
phrase that people say when they speak
about life is life as we know it i
always found it to be interesting life
as we know it
because again like coming from math you
just have the definitions you just say
here are the necessary and sufficient
conditions and then that's it to say
some so and so as we know it
implies that there could be something
else why by what
we have to call that life it's as if we
have an intuitive feeling as to what
life is and we point to certain examples
and say this is living this is not
living we haven't quite captured it with
our explicit language but it's there
implicitly that's the only way that i
can make sense of life as we know it but
i mean i think that i think there's an
emotional charge to that phrase life as
we know it says
out there there is life as we don't know
it or there may be life as we don't know
it and and our little limited experience
is really just a tiny kind of bit of the
possible universal possibilities i i
think we we all as human beings thrill
to the idea that there could be
something
majestic out there life as we don't know
it something much bigger than the human
mind to consider and you know god would
probably fall into that category but
um
but that's kind of make-believe in some
sense
because it it it doesn't ask the
question so so
what
would it be like then what are the what
are the principles that govern life as
we know it and and are they binding
principles or are they
uh loose and could it be many other
different kinds of ways and you know
it's
i think one of the most powerful ideas
in biology is is natural selection and
and again a lot of physicists have a
problem with natural selection because
it's just so damn simple and easy and
it's hard to believe that
that something as trivial as that can be
as profound as that
um
but but it's it's becomes amazingly
complex it
becomes the stuff that
that can be explained by by
by how selection works is genuinely
astonishing
it's so rich as an idea you know i mean
you're talking about ideas in physics
that the the fewer parameters you can
boil it down to i mean natural selection
gets it down to very few parameters uh
with enormous possibilities and reach
um
and
biology as a discipline has spent you
know 100 years or more thinking about
well how does selection actually work
what are the units of selection is
acting on genes on cells on organisms on
groups and so on
and i would say we we have a fairly
decent understanding of a lot of it um
and it's it's um you know
it's it's capable of
it's capable of amazing feats but the
actual processes underlying it are are
quite simple and rely in in the end on
forms of copying
and richard dawkins has talked about
memes and so on and and yes they they
can copy and cultural cultural evolution
can happen but it requires the units of
living people underneath it with a
central nervous system which is capable
of propagating a meme and so on or a
computer which is capable of
in the end making copies of itself so
you know ai can come alive i have no
no real
doubt about that but i don't think that
a planet
can bootstrap itself up from nothing
to give ai kind of without without the
intermediary of humans along the way
or or at least complex animals capable
of
because i don't think that silicon
as a tool is ever going to get beyond
sand
uh on a planetary scale carbon is so
much better at what it does it may be
limited compared to silicon in the end
in terms of processing power but but in
terms of how do you start you know what
you have with with carbon is a lego
brick you have co2 it sits there in the
atmosphere you pluck it out of the
atmosphere and you build your amazing
lego kits which is life
um and and with silicon or something
you're dealing with a pile of sand it
just it doesn't work at the same level
we can fashion it so that it works his
life but it's never going to come alive
by itself
when i was younger and i was watching
the discovery channel
there was i remember hearing this phrase
that hey if life exists on other planets
maybe it's silicon based because silicon
serves the same purpose as carbon i
don't know i was too young to understand
what that meant and i haven't followed
up on that since you just reminded me of
it right now so is that indeed true or
not that silicon is just as versatile no
it's not nearly as versatile and that's
the problem i mean carbon forms much
stronger bonds
than silicon does it's capable of
forming much more interesting molecules
than silicon ever can
uh and silicon for the most part forms
silicon oxides which are
sand
um and and they're basically giant macro
molecules that a single grain of sand is
an enormous number of atoms in it and
it's just a repeating pattern of those
atoms it's a it's a giant crystal it's
not a building block a single co2 is a
building block you you know it's it's
like a brick um it's your lego brick
whereas
uh
you know i suppose trying to build from
silicon would be like trying to build
from enormous piles of lego and try to
put two piles together and fashion it
into some kind of unit
i recall you saying that the fact that
bacteria are limited in size on earth at
least has some implication for life in
the universe i don't remember the line
of reasoning so please if you know what
i'm referring to can you expound on that
yes i mean it's really an observation
on earth that bacteria are they're not
always tiny
but they're mostly to a first
approximation they're small they're
they're a couple of micrometers long and
and that that's that's that's it
um and when you look at them under a
conventional microscope you don't see
very much going on
um
now in terms of their biochemistry in
terms of the molecular machines and all
of these things they're enormously
sophisticated in terms of their
genomes they've got a different
structure to their genome so a single e
coli cell
might have about 4 000 genes and we have
about 20 000 genes
but an e coli has what's called a
metagenome which is to say other e coli
have different genomes and they swap
genes among themselves so an e coli
might have a kind of access to a genome
with 30 000 genes
which gives it a lot more scope for
changing for evolving for for switching
about
um
but it means that no two e coli are
exactly identical to each other and they
all have a small genome and and that
tends to mean that if you try and build
a multicellular organism from cells
which are genetically different to each
other
then what you end up with is a you know
a fight basically that would put fights
between different human groups were
basically genetically close to identical
to each other
um in the shade you know what we're
dealing with cells that are you know
utterly different to each other more
difference between two e coli cells and
the entire vertebrate kingdom
um interesting it's yeah it's it's huge
differences you you put them together
and
you're never going to make
anything as complex as a flea out of
bacterial cells because they don't have
a large enough genome what we do is we
have a large genome and we switch these
genes on in the brain and we switch
those genes on in the kidneys and these
genes in the in in the heart and so on
we're all genetically identical but we
switch off different genes in different
that now to get a genome that's that big
requires i think
the kind of radical restructuring of
genomes
and the reason for that is that
any giant bacteria that we see and there
are a few around they always have
thousands of copies of their complete
genome dotted right next to the membrane
and it seems that they're there because
they they need to control this
electrical charge on the membrane
which is
which is the charge which is i'm saying
is is responsible for consciousness but
it's responsible for driving co2
fixation and for making energy the
currency the the atp currency of life
and so on it's it's used for
pretty much everything and it's a charge
which is enormously strong so if you
shrink yourself down to a size of a
molecule again and
the electrical field strength that you
would experience if you're sitting next
to that membrane is 30 million volts per
meter which is equivalent to a bolt of
lightning
so we're dealing with a membrane which
is five millionths of a meter thick five
nanometers thick um
five millionths of a millimeter sorry
thick
um so 10 to the minus nine of a meter um
so
so it's enormously thin and the charge
across it is about 100 millivolts or 150
millivolts or something like that and
any but it but as a field strength
that's very high
you need genes to control that they need
to be next to it and the problem with
bacteria is if they try and just expand
up you end up with this enormous cost of
having all of these genomes sitting next
to that now what we have with
mitochondria
we have
the same what's called extreme
polyploidy we've got thousands of copies
of the mitochondrial genome but they've
been whittled down to almost nothing
there's only
um i mean there's that there's
i think
uh
38 genes in in the mitochondria
left in in humans
and they only are encoding the machinery
and the proteins that are doing
respiration that's it so they're
basically you could think of them as
the same power as a bacterium to to to
to generate energy but without all the
overhead costs that a normal bacterium
would have so we've got multi-bacterial
power like multi-horsepower or something
and what that allows us is to have a
swollen nuclear genome with with 20 000
genes and lots of regulatory capacity
and lots of energy for expressing those
genes so that we we can make tens of
thousands of copies of the protein
rather than just a thousand copies or
something so we we we we can scale up in
a way that is is basically impossible
for bacteria and and that came about as
a result of an endosymbiosis which is to
say one cell gets inside another cell
which is pretty rare in itself and it
has to survive there and you know
they have to get along
so the whole
history
of complex life on earth is a history of
of um
antagonism and cooperation and
eventually overcoming the obstacles and
the hurdles and and becoming integrated
as a as a functional unit
i didn't realize that there were only 38
genes in the mitochondria that sounds so
tiny
it's very few and for that reason
they're they're mostly ignored
so
so the people who work on the human
genomes 20 000 genes want to sequence
the genome look to see which genes are
responsible for diseases
people do what are called g-wise studies
which is a genome
wide association studies so you you look
for
this this single letter change here or
that one there is associated with
epilepsy or alzheimer's disease or
whatever it may be and maybe there's
maybe there's a few hundred of these or
maybe there's thousands or millions of
them but
a few hundred may may kind of crop up
and say ah people who've got that letter
changed their slightly higher risk of
alzheimer's disease and if they've got
this one as well it's a little bit more
and people ignore the mitochondria but
the mitochondria
what makes us alive this is the
difference between just information
and a living system
where it's growing where it's capable of
of
powering all the work that cells need to
do you get anything wrong with those
genes or they don't work properly with a
nuclear background and you've
compromised the entire living system
so they they are there's not many of
them but they are the most important
genes
for
making us who we are you may say
for making us alive for for being
for being here at all and mitochondria
they have dna or rna
they have dna
yeah
they have rna as well but they they the
genome is made of dna
the blob of
of dna in the nucleus is that called
nuclear dna
yes
okay so there's mitochondrial dna
there's nucleus and dna yes all right
all right and they better work together
right right right i read that there was
some i in your book that there's some
compatibility condition between the
mitochondrial dna and the nuclear dna
and i think doug wallace was
investigating this and he took my dna
and then put into hamster yeah yeah that
was that was quite a long time ago lots
of people have done i've done similar
work since then but even within you know
so so some of my own work is on
drosophila uh different groups of
drosophila
um we're all within the same species but
if you kind of mismatch their
mitochondrial dna to to the nuclear
background
then
it increases
the risk of all kind i mean basically
the rate at which some flies age
compared to others or how fertile they
are there's
various kind of phenotypes and exactly
the same principles should apply to
humans as well
and somehow this is a driving force or
at least is proposed to be a driving
force behind speciation and i don't
recall how that line of
reasoning went
do you know what i'm referring to yes so
so so the idea and this is uh this is
i won't say it's a speculative idea but
there's there's not very much evidence
that it's really true but it's a it's a
very interesting idea
um
so
in effect if because mitochondrial genes
evolve much faster
than genes in the nucleus about 10 times
faster on average maybe more maybe 50
times faster we don't actually really
know
um
but they're they're changing very
quickly now this this selection
happening in the female germ line so
whenever um whenever
new oocytes egg cells are being made
there's a process of of um
effectively winnowing out the bad
mitochondria and and and
bringing the the better mitochondria
together and an egg cell has as many as
half a million mitochondria and copies
of mitochondrial dna in that egg cell
and they're all as close to a clone as
it's possible to make them without
without kind of killing yourself in the
process
um
and these genes are evolving very
quickly
and
can
effectively fail to interact properly
with the
genes in the nucleus so if you imagine
two populations that are diverging and
you know standard idea of speciation
there's two there's two populations are
on different sides of a mountain and
they
they they they don't mix for for you
know thousands of generations or
something and then and then they come
back together again and they mix
and so which genes are going to be
involved so sometimes they'll intermix
perfectly well and other times there
will be um some kind of it's called
hybrid breakdown basically the the
offspring which is the the standard
biological definition of a species is if
you can't produce viable offspring
if the offspring of sterile or or
don't develop properly
then you've you've got two different
species very often different species can
interbreed perfectly well this is a very
bad definition of a species it's another
example in biology where where
there isn't a firm definition
there's just separate now the genes that
are evolving the fastest and changing
the fastest the mitochondrial genes are
the ones that are most likely
to cause trouble in those circumstances
they're the ones most likely to
not work well with the nuclear
background of the other population from
the other side of the mountain
this is the idea
um and and so
incipient speciation may be driven by
the rate of change of the mitochondria
which may you know if these guys live in
a hot climate and these guys live in a
cold climate then maybe the mitochondria
are specialized to different tasks and
that can drive these differences what
we've found with uh with with fly is
interestingly enough is
um
that the you can end up with 50 or 60
different letter changes
in in mitochondrial dna which is quite a
lot
um and
whether or not you have
observable
problems
for example not developing properly or
aging very quickly or not doesn't depend
on the number of the differences you
might expect to be a correlation if
you've got 50
50 letters different then then it's more
likely to go wrong than if you've only
got five letters different
and that's not the case what we actually
find is it's an absolute flat line that
if you've got five letters or one letter
difference it can cause some
catastrophic problems if they're bad
letters
and if you've got 50 letters difference
um then then
uh it is it you know it can it can be
catastrophically bad or it can be fine
there is not necessarily any worse and
this these are the levels of differences
that we see across humans as well there
is no
you know there is a possibility
that different
human races could interbreed and then
produce produce offspring that were not
functional no one's ever seen it but
it's it's a theoretical possibility that
this work seems to say no way that's not
going to happen
because we can see individuals who have
a problem because there's an unfortunate
mismatch and incompatibility
that
we've always known about these things
two people just don't work together for
whatever reason um
but it's nothing to do with
with races or with speciation
once you've got really deep divergence
say between a mouse and a rat or
something between a chimpanzee and a
human being then you would see
then you would see certain now we're
dealing with thousands of thousands of
letter changes difference and and then
you'll begin to see that there really is
some kind of breakdown but within within
populations that are basically
homogeneous as the human populations are
we don't see those changes how many
letters make up the mitochondrial dna do
you know approximately
um
it's about eighteen thousand
eighteen to ten oh wow great great great
great memory okay and then dna is
drastically more sorry nuclear dna is
far more
oh we're dealing with about three
billion then okay why is it so strange
that
certain mutations so certain letter
changes in the mitochondrial dna
produce
horrible effects but then certain other
changes don't because that sounds the
same as nuclear dna and you were saying
like oh it's so strange one or two
letters off here but 50 letters well
that troubled me a lot and i didn't
understand it it's not what i expected
um and i actually find it quite welcome
in a strange way but it took me a long
time to understand
why what's going on there
and and
i think the reason is that there has to
be
quite a lot of tolerance
for different types of mitochondrial
function
so
women and men are different
in in in
in in dietary needs in in outputs of one
sort or another in metabolic rate
on average men have about 20 percent
higher metabolic rate than women do
so there are all these there are all
these differences and and the
mitochondria we inherit them from our
mothers only
um and that means in principle that they
adapt to being
in in in the female line
and
you know your mitochondria my
mitochondria they're going nowhere if
you have kids then then they're not
going to get your mitochondria your
mitochondria you're going in the bin
um and that means that
they can never really be fashioned to
work
to be adapted to being in men
um now the nuclear background can kind
of
fashion them to work in men
and the y chromosome for example can you
know can control genes that up regulates
those that make female mitochondria
effectively work better in men
um
so there's there are biological ways
around this but the bottom line is
um
there are different requirements on the
system in men and women but there are
different requirements as well depending
on
is it in the brain where
the genes that are expressed in the
nucleus is a completely different set of
genes compared to those in the kidney
where the mitochondria have a different
task and the same genes in the
mitochondria have to work with a
different set of nuclear genes with
different requirements so they basically
they've got to be generalists they've
got to have a lot of
slack that they can
operate well enough in completely
different tissues completely different
diets
you know different human groups have
very different diets and and and
different different um
you know
fat intake or or calorie intake or
whatever it may be that puts pressures
on on mitochondrial functions which can
be very different different temperatures
um that you're operating at um
and especially that's even even worse
with things like flies that are cold
blooded and if you change the
temperature then their whole body
temperature changes
so so they're basically they have to be
generalist and that means that they they
can tolerate a fair amount of of change
and most of the changes that happen
um are tolerated
but some of them are not um and and if
if you are unlucky enough to have a
change that is not tolerated then it it
affects all of the organs it affects
both the sexes it affects absolutely
everything
um and so so then you then you've got a
problem
because it's so fundamental just to the
process of living
i believe there's a concept called
mother's curse which is about okay so
firstly if you don't mind saying what
that is and then also why can't we
follow the same logic of mother's curse
and say that men should have drastically
shorter lifespans or be
far worse off i mean maybe this what may
be a why question well men do how men do
have shorter life spans
um by about five or six years i think on
average something of that order um so
mother's curse i i've actually kind of
already described this in a way
it's it's basically because
the mitochondria pass down the female
line so they're inherited from mother to
daughter to daughter to daughter and so
on um
they become
any any mutation
which is
bad
for
the daughter
would
um be selected against
whereas any mutation that is is is fine
for the daughter but bad for the sun
is not necessarily going to be selected
against because the sun's mitochondria
are not going anywhere they're a dead
end
so there's no direct selection there can
be indirect selection they can be you
know if all your sons die then they can
be you know indirect forms of selection
but there's no direct selection on them
and so mutations that are effectively if
there are differences between females
and males in metabolic requirements and
there are
and and the the mitochondria passed down
the female line only which they do
and some mutations may be harmless or
even beneficial to women but detrimental
to men
then selection will select for the ones
which are harmless or detrimental in
women and the the harmful ones to men
will tend to accumulate there's no
mechanism of selecting against no direct
mechanism of selecting against them so
that's mother's curse
and
you know a lot of mitochondrial diseases
for example and you know two or three
times more common in men than in women
a lot of diseases that have a
mitochondrial aspect to them like
parkinson's disease are twice as common
in in men than in women
and men age more quickly and and die
earlier than women and all of these
things have a mitochondrial component
and may be linked in some way to
mother's curse so it's it's real
but the i i use the word direct
selection on several occasions
the the genes in the nucleus can
compensate
and so for the most part
um most most men don't have
mitochondrial diseases and and men live
almost as long as women and and so on so
mostly
the the fact that we inherit
mitochondria that could be riddled with
mutations that are not good for men
are compensated for by genes in the
nucleus that are specifically male which
effectively offset those disadvantages
and this is where the problem if you if
you then um
if you if you then go and
breed with a completely different
population that doesn't have those
compensating genes in the nucleus that's
where this speciation effect can
potentially come in
and these compensating genes in the
nucleus
they don't detrimentally affect women
are they relegated to the y chromosome
for example um yes i mean there are
so so there are you know there
there are differences in what's called
gene expression between men and women
which is to say
um the y chromosome controls it but
there's only a handful of genes on the y
chromosome but those genes
say you you you
you you you
shut down um and so you know it biology
is not about which genes you have so
much as which genes are active now and
on a specific stage of development and
so on
um and and so
there are
you know that
in men the the genes which are expressed
at a certain time
uh can be
very different
yeah geez it's it's staggering
staggering
the complexity does your head in there's
no question yeah
so okay now let's talk about what's not
complex well maybe it's complex but i
haven't made an analogy between the cell
and the planet because one is charged on
the inside and okay can you talk about
that that's interesting and then i
wondered how far does that analogy go
does it go to the galaxy i mean
yes i mean no i don't think it would go
to the galaxy level but it um and it is
an analogy
it's it's not
i mean i i i i i think you will be
unwise to take it too far but it's a
kind of a beautiful analogy and there's
definitely some truth in it i mean a
cell
is in effect
this electrical charge on the membrane
that i keep talking about on the inside
um
it's basically saturated in electrons
we've got organic molecules have taken
co2 and they've added hydrogen on and
hydrogen is an electron and a proton
basically um and so
and so in in making organic molecules
we've taken electrons from the outside
and put them inside
and so it's it's reduced it's more
reduced inside than it is outside that's
the technical term and reduced is one of
those terms that
you know
anybody who's not a chemist backs away
from him immediately just tries to
escape from the room
um so oxidized and reduced but
in effect there's more electrons inside
than outside okay and and there's more
protons
there's more negative insight yes yeah
um
and so is relatively positive outside
and
there are protons outside that's partly
what makes it
more positive outside and we've got this
we've got this charge on the membrane
which is basically the is relatively
positive outside relatively negative
inside and the membrane itself is
extremely thin
uh and so we have a charge on it now the
planet is basically the same
um
iron raw iron is is is electron dense
you might say most iron that people are
from when rus when iron rusts it's
effectively losing electrons to oxygen
oxygen stripping those electrons from it
and you end up with with three positive
charges on the ion the ion atom itself
ends up with three positive charges and
the oxygen gets the electrons and that
has a negative charge and you know you
have iron hydroxides and oxides and so
on and that's what rust is
um
now
the core of the planet is not rusty at
all there's no oxygen down there it's
got all these electrons sitting on the
iron um
and so it's relatively negative inside
and the outside the the atmosphere and
the oceans and so on um
because the gases that are coming from
volcanoes and so on are such a high
temperature they tend to have lost their
electrons and think you can get you get
gases like carbon dioxide
uh coming coming out
and the sun will also tend to oxidize
the surface the planet will would tend
to for example you can the sun would
split water
water is h2o and it can be split in
effect into hydrogen and oxygen
and the hydrogen is light enough to
escape
uh into space
and the oxygen will react with rocks
like iron and and you get rusty rocks
and this is more or less what happened
on mars that's why it's the red planet
the oxygen that was formed from spitting
water reacted with iron in the rocks
turning the rusty red color and the
hydrogen escape to space a lot of the
oceans were were lost that way on mars
um
and so you end up with an with a kind of
a relatively positive charge in the
atmosphere and this relatively negative
charge inside which is basically the
same structure as a cell
and just as a cell membrane has
proteins that sit in it where you have
movement between the inside and the
outside hydrothermal vents are the
equivalent kind of
conductance between
between the
the the negative charge of the interior
and the positive charge of the exterior
uh it's you have movement going through
through vents
connecting it up
and within these vents the pores inside
the vents have got the same structure as
well they're effectively inside they're
filled with the material that came from
inside the earth and the outside they're
surrounded by the material that came
from the from the oceans and so again we
have a negative charge inside positive
charge outside relative to each other
it's not that there's an actual charge
it's just that there's a
the electrons want to move from here to
there
now do you believe this to be a
coincidence or that life is somehow
mimicking cellular life is somehow no i
i don't think it's a coincidence at all
i think this is exactly how cells work
and
that
what this is doing is there's
effectively there's an electrical charge
on the earth between the inside and the
outside there's an electrical charge and
the pores in these hydrothermal vents
between the inside and the outside
there's electrical charge on cells
between the inside and the outside
they're all
equivalent topology
because they've all been formed
from the same process as you might say
because the hydrothermal vents is where
there is the mixing zone between the
inside and the outside so it naturally
forms pores where we have this the same
charges forming and those charges
are more or less necessary to drive the
reaction between hydrogen and carbon
dioxide to make the organic molecules
that make up life at all
um so
i find it a beautiful conception it
doesn't mean it's true but i find it
beautiful that the the planet has the
same
basic topological structure as a cell
cells emerged from the the the the the
mixing zone between the inside and the
outside effectively part of the circuit
um and and are driving copies of
themselves by making more miniature
earths if you like
um
by
reacting the hydrogen from the inside
with the co2 from the outside to make
organic molecules it's a it's a
planetary scale and it's a beautiful
conception
something i love about you is firstly
you write beautifully and secondly you
are not afraid to ask why and you
mentioned this that you're the most
biologists don't like to ask the why
question perhaps because it teeters too
much on the religious side and they
would like to stay away or for whatever
reason physicists don't like to as well
there's a famous or an infamous video of
feynman who is castigating a fairly at
least in my opinion well-intentioned
interviewer for asking a why question
you recall that
i don't remember that one no i mean i
love listening to feinman but yes he
could castigate people
i thought it was a perfectly reasonable
question and feynman said yeah but you
shouldn't ask why because so and so so
why is it that you
don't mind asking why and why and and
simultaneously why do others not like
asking why
i
to be honest i don't really know i mean
it's partly i'm just confused and i
can't tell the difference between how
and why
um
and i think most biochemists are happy
asking how how does this system work
um and i can't quite distinguish that
from
from why why is it working this way
rather than a different way that's kind
of almost another way of saying how
and
i think
why is one of the most human questions
and it's a childlike question
children always want to know why and and
i think it's the motivation for many
people to go into science and one of the
things about science is it tries to stop
you from being too naive and tries to
impose a method on you to
to be objective and to not ask questions
that are
unanswerable in some way to stick to the
as i mentioned the art of the soluble
before
we'll never know why but but we can't
help asking why and as i say i can't
tell the difference between why and how
anyway so um it's very exciting asking
why
and um
and perhaps it's more forgiven in books
than it is in in in papers and and you
know the more scientific literature
books i think are a good place to ask
why
um
and uh and maybe that's why i write
books in part because it gives me this
outlet to wonder about things to wonder
about the world and in the end that is
what science is it's about
how do we explain the world which is to
say why is the world this way when it
could have been so many other ways i
think why is it is in fact you know it's
a question in physics why are the
cosmological constants that way rather
than some other way that's the theory of
everything supposed to explain that um
it's a why question
to me
you could say how did it come to be that
way
i see the strengths of science as being
what you mentioned the focusing on
what's soluble and then the weakness is
also that too
the reason why i say that but i don't
know how to solve this so i'm just gonna
pose this as a question
if one was to go into a phd program but
produced no papers in four years or
produced papers with all negative
results then you would likely not be
hired and so yes when you're
a young person when you're at your most
creative
you're disincentivized for pursuing wild
ideas that because most likely they
won't work but they may also lead to
breakthroughs
now there's a bit of a tragedy about
that it means that we we prioritize
certain incremental progress yes versus
these substantial things absolutely
agree and now you know i i my lab mostly
works on the origin of life and and uh
you know i have phd students and
post-docs and so on and i face this
problem every day
um that
most of the results we get are negative
um
what are we going to do
uh how do i
you know i don't want my
students to all fail to publish any
papers fail to get any positive results
and finish their careers that's the last
thing i i want for them
um
so
so you've got to juggle
you've got to you've got to aim for the
lowest hanging fruit you've got to keep
the big picture at the back of your mind
and try to think of experiments that
that will
um
work in one way or
another um
and and you've got to not forget about
the the bigger questions behind it and
keep on trying them so i think you have
to move people around
so that if something starts working
and one students had two years of
getting nothing then you've got to give
them something where they're going to
get something now
um that you know
it's it's difficult and it's difficult
not because of the scientific question
so much because the human aspect of
people's careers that they need to be
able to come out of it with
with um
you know a career ahead of them
something to look forward to why do you
think it is that negative results aren't
seen as worthy as or as worthy as
positive results because to me just as
an outsider i see this as data even if
you were to say so and so it doesn't
work great now i know so-and-so doesn't
work there's the replication crisis in
psychology yes particularly because
people are incentivized to find
affirming or new results rather than
disconfirming
i think it's um
i mean we've got a
a paper coming up um
it's probably going to be under embargo
but it's actually is out there as a
pre-print anyway so i'll tell you about
it anyway exclusive to toe
uh this is this is about how how atp
is uh formed now we've found this is
silvana pinner who did her phd with me
and she finished a while ago and and
this is her
big paper
from this and what she found was
actually what she did was was
effectively repeat some earlier work
from a japanese group
um from 20 years ago and they had found
by chance
that
um a corroding iron electrode
uh when they got adp in solution
around that electrode i actually formed
some atp
and they they looked into it and it
turned out that ferric iron which is say
iron with three positive charges on it
um
will catalyze
um the formation this had to be in the
presence of something called acetyl
phosphate which is just a two carbon
compound
would catalyze the the phosphorylation
of adp to atp which is what our
mitochondria are doing all the time
but instead of having all this molecular
machinery like the atp synthase it's
just happening in water with ferric iron
as the only catalyst so that's pretty
amazing
so she repeated this it took a while to
figure out exactly how they'd done it
and this is very often the case and for
a period i remember we were concerned
that it would not be
possible to replicate it
and then she succeeded in replicating it
um
and that's i i find that increasingly
pleasing
just simply to replicate other people's
work because of this problem that
sometimes you know it's sometimes it's
made up
sometimes
sometimes it's not as cynical as that
but it's for whatever reason there was
some aspect of chance that allowed it to
you know
to be able to replicate science i think
is the perhaps the single most important
thing in science and and so it's very
pleasing when you succeed in doing it
now she is the probably the single most
careful uh scientist that i've ever met
she she really uh is is amazingly
precise you could never see her error
bars
because
the repeats were so so similar to each
other this really wasn't one um
but all her all the rest of her data was
negative
which was very interesting she so so he
worked with ferric iron but she tried
with about 10 other different metal ions
and none of the other metal ions worked
and she tried with about seven or eight
different phosphorylating agents instead
of acetyl phosphate and none of those
worked and she tried with the other
bases so instead of adp she tried with
gdp and cdps or the other letters in in
rna and udp and so on none of those
worked either
so this is a paper made up entirely of
negative data apart from one result
which had actually been done by someone
else 20 years earlier and replicated by
still manner and the
now this is where negative data really
comes into its own
because
it it basically says there is something
favored
about adp compared to the other bases
and about acetal phosphate compared to
the other phosphorylating ages and about
this metal iron compared to those other
metal ions this is favored chemistry why
is it favored we could come up with a
mechanism for it and so on
but there the negative data is
effectively saying there's a limited
number of ways that this will happen
um
and and here's one way where it does
maybe there are other ways that does as
well and we just look at those some
other metal iron that was not in our
panel um you know you can have huge
combinatorial panels but we looked at
all the metal ions that seem to have any
relevance to life or any relevance to
geochemistry and this ferric ion was the
only one that worked
now
the problem
the problem there
is that imagine that ferric iron didn't
work either then you would have a paper
where everything was negative
let's just say that she didn't know
about that paper and that she never
tried ferric iron and that she tried all
the others what she would have had would
have been a completely negative set of
data
which
would be unpublishable because
um nothing worked now
maybe if she tried some other ions
then it would have worked like ferric
ion did but if you don't happen to
choose that one then you'll never know
and so you can never rule something out
you can never you know if all your data
is negative it doesn't mean it can't
work it just means that everything we
tried under the conditions that we tried
it it never did work
and at that point we decided to pull the
project because this poor phd student's
never going to get a paper out of it
that we we explored it as well as we
could but the reality is we've got to
move on and so you've never disproved it
but you've kind of just given up trying
to prove it now
whereas the fact that someone had done
it before meant that that was the one
that she tried first which meant that
when we when the paper comes now we have
something which is really exciting which
is to say the reason that atp is the
universal energy currency is precisely
that it works as prebiotic chemistry in
water or by itself just with one metal
ion as a catalyst and that works and
nothing else does work and that's why
it's this way so suddenly you've got a
very sexy message
um which in the end is based on the fact
that someone else had
found
out something 20 years ago that was
really a serendipitous discovery that
they were not applying to the origin of
life or anything else it's just you know
and and science is built this way
science is built on it's kind of network
of the efforts of different people doing
different things for different reasons
and you try and put it together and
you've got to you know juggle what works
what doesn't work when do you give up
and and very rarely can you ever
disprove anything formally in a way that
a physicist would understand disprove
just you know
it's
that's why the positive results are
important because
they are
they give you something to say
whereas the negative results don't give
you anything to say they just say
everything we tried didn't work it's
possible that something else would have
worked
but we don't know because we didn't do
that so that's not it's not going to
sell any papers
i'm not entirely sure about that well
you would know in your domain but in
physics there's something called no go
theorems so for example there's the no
go theorem which says that you can't
have a graviton in 4d quantum field
theory and then that then you're like
well what's the hope for gravity and
then that's one of the reasons why
people think that there's ads cft
correspondence the holographic principle
because okay there there was a hidden
assumption that wasn't stated by whitten
actually and he's a careful person which
is that you can't have a graviton in
your same three plus one quantum field
theory but you can in a different
quantum field theory so you can have
that's why you have this universe within
another border okay but anyway so a
negative result can still lead to
breakthroughs like it leads to hope
there's ads cft is like almost a whole
field in and of itself the way that when
i hear this what i'm wondering is hmm
why is it not the case that studies in
different fields
pre-register i don't know if this is
forgive me if i'm speaking out well i
think a lot of clinical trials
pre-register in that sense so a clinical
trial that is negative
and there you're you know there it's
often funded by a pharmaceutical company
or something you have some interest in
not publishing negative data but the the
regulators or the other you know it's in
it's in the public interest that it
should be published and and so this idea
of pre-registering
is uh is a good one but the there's a
there's a kind of a big difference
the big clinical trials
um are are
they're very expensive to set up they're
very constrained in the way in which
they're set up they're only
there there's kind of statistically
um
they've been set up so statistically
they can demonstrate a difference
between a treatment or a different
treatment or no treatment or whatever it
may be
um so
so
they come up with you know they they
come up with an outcome and and the
chances are
it's going to be about as reliable a
statement as you can make
um but it's very unwieldy it might take
five years to do it it might cost 20
million pounds or something it's where's
a lot of a lot of smaller scale science
is much more maneuverable
you can you know if
no phd student would ever
no and i mean there's also this
competitive side in science as well
whereas if you told everybody what you
were doing then they would do it quicker
than you could so there's the you know
there's there's some element in which
uh people don't want to say what they're
doing necessarily i'm not sure that
that's a good thing but it is the
reality
basically what i was saying what i was
thinking is that hey the negative
results themselves maybe there were 30
other people across
the history of biology that have tried
to formulate atp
using those metals that didn't work but
sylvana your assistant couldn't sorry
you're a phd student correct
yes yes your phd student couldn't
didn't see the literature because
everyone else said no and so then she
wasted her time too and those 29 other
people wasted their time and i was
thinking well then if you publish
negative results does that just bloat
all the journals or like is there
another reason to not well i mean the
journal the journals are already bloated
i i actually think that
um
reading too much of the journals is not
good for you
um which is to say
when when i have new students starting
very often they're encouraged to do a
literature review and they'll often get
bogged down because literature is
overwhelming there's so much of it out
there and and it's written in such a way
as to
imply that the results that they did
were decisive in some way um and you'll
come out with the feeling that
everything's been done and there's
really nothing left to do here and
well i you might as well despair at that
point
um so it's actually much more productive
not to know about any of that to to be
deliberately ignorant
and to just blunder around for a while
until you begin to see something and
then at that point is the time to access
the literature so has have other people
done this before and the answer is often
yes they have but we did this bit
different and we did that bit different
and they did this but we did that and so
on and so on and so um
you often end up getting different
results to what they got and you realize
that well if we'd just taken for granted
what they said and didn't do anything we
would never have found that
so
and and and if you find exactly the same
as them then that's kind of nice to know
as well and you'll probably try and drop
it into a paper somewhere just to make
it clear that this you have successfully
replicated someone else's work it's
worth saying that you've done that
but but very often you know a paper may
close down an area by saying this is not
possible and in fact they were wrong
because they did the wrong experiment
and there's so many possible experiments
you can do that so long as you don't
close yourself down by believing them
then you'll go on and find something new
so i
i would sing the praises of uh of
blundering around in ignorance in the
scientific undergrowth because it's the
way to make progress
let's wrap i just got to use the
washroom once more and i would be remiss
if i didn't ask you carl fristan's
questions he sent me some to ask you
uh
right yeah
is that all right of course it is yes
now this question comes from carl
fristen number one is the increase in
diversity and complexity of phenotypic
forms a universal feature of evolution
and if so
is there any principled explanation for
this
um
i mean this the simple answer is
yes
uh and
i suppose the reason is simply mutations
um which leads to diversity
so
mutations are almost impossible to i
mean all of all of evolution is based on
mutations and they have
an enormous power
um
this the standard
the standard way of seeing
natural selection from a population
genetics point of view so i'm not a
population geneticist but i'm in the
department of genetics and uh
and i work with some population
geneticists who
uh you know worked with some of the
the the founding fathers of the field
people like jbs haldane and john maynard
smith and so on um
and that
field kind of only lets itself see
detrimental mutations which is to say
mutations that are bad for you in one
way or another now we know that there
are
neutral mutations most mutations are
neutral don't make really much of a
difference
and there are a few beneficial mutations
but the ones that are
effectively bad detrimental
are are the ones that the field of
population genetics has historically
really focused on because they are the
ones that are most likely to be selected
against
so neutral ones will be ignored by
selection or almost ignored beneficial
ones are very rare in comparison and and
detrimental mutations are very common
um and i find this uh i find this quite
difficult to get used to because i want
to think positively about
about beneficial mutations
but
i've become used to thinking in this
framework and i'm shocked at how much
power it has so we have a paper out just
recently with another phd student of
mine who's a physicist by training uh
marco colnagi
and this is asking
about
bacteria i mentioned earlier on bacteria
have this metagenome where they an e
coli might have 4 000 genes but access
to 30 000 genes from out there somewhere
um
and and they do what's called lateral or
horizontal gene transfer which is they
pick up bits of dna from the environment
and they bind it into themselves
uh and various people have shown that
this
is a little bit equivalent to sex which
is to say it's doing recombination it's
changing the gene set that you've got
and even if on average you pick up genes
that are worse than the ones you've got
on average you'll benefit from it
because you're generating variation that
selection can act on and if selection
sees differences between individuals
then it will
it will
select against the ones with the
detrimental mutations and the ones don't
have them will
will flourish and so on
so basically selection is all about the
differences between individuals and
mutations generate differences between
individuals but moving genes around
bilateral gene transfer amplifies those
differences
and sex is an extraordinary machine for
generating differences between
individuals
and it uses the same machinery that
bacteria use but it organizes it
completely different and so there's this
question why
and the answer i i think we've we've
found part of the answer at least um
i mentioned mitochondria before that
mitochondria allow you to have a much
larger genome
and and having a very large genome gives
you a problem with preventing it from
being degraded by mutations
and the way that bacteria prevent the
genomes being degraded by mutations is
picking up bits of dna from around
around the place and patching it in
and it works for a bacterial sized
genome but if you have a much larger
genome and let's say five times larger
and you pick up a random bit of dna from
the environment in effect the chances of
you getting the right bit is is much
lower
and really the only way around it is to
pick up large chunks
of dna from the environment and then
there's a problem that you if if you've
got any
any
sequences that match somewhere else in
your genome and this is more like the
larger your genome the more likely to
have repeat sequence as you are the more
likely to delete information you are
when you bring this bit in and throw
away your bit
so you end up
with a system which is
only set up to
eliminate detrimental mutations
can account for
the transition from bacterial lateral
gene transfer to what's called meiosis
and and sex where you like where you
bring two cells together they fuse
together they line up the chromosomes
and so on um
so the whole the whole thing
is based on generating differences
between individuals so that selection
can act so to come back around in a
large circle to carl fristan's question
about divergence between things is
driven by mutations and it's basically
inevitable and it will be a property of
any biological system that's got
information at the base of it
all right he has a second question it's
right carl fristen says what is the role
of sequestration and isolation in
evolution at the molecular or cellular
scale
sequestration
yeah sequestration
um
so i'm not quite sure what he
specifically had in mind there
um
i just sent him a message once more over
a chat
yeah
so
yes i mean what i immediately think of
uh when when when i read sequestration
is sequestration within cells which is
to say you have compartments you
sequester
the machinery for respiration within the
compartment of mitochondria for example
now i don't know if that's actually what
he had in mind
but there's a lovely point about
bacteria which is that they are
essentially indivisible
they don't have any sequestrated bits so
there isn't
a compartment which is responsible for
respiration there isn't a compartment
which is responsible for you know
putting the genes in and for protecting
genes and so on it's a single open
system with a mem noise well it's not a
super it's actually got quite a lot of
structure
um there's a lot of interest these days
in phase separations between
effectively uh liquid liquid phase
separations and and you know the the
genes in in a bacterial cell are phase
separated from the cytosol
and there's no membrane between the two
of them so the compartment is
not a complete compartment in the same
way whereas the mitochondria have got a
membrane around them and it sequestrates
the inside of the mitochondria from the
rest of the cell and that allows you to
have enormously more power it allows you
to
charge up those membranes from the
inside let me just give one example to
do with with um
with sequestration and mitochondria
um
when when anybody thinks
of a mitochondria they'll tend to think
of a kind of sausage-shaped thing with
membranes inside the cell and there are
all these sausage-shaped things in there
and that's not really how they are at
all
um they will actually fuse together
they're very dynamic they're moving
around they fuse together they fission
apart they separate out but a lot of the
time they're fused together into a giant
network
uh which which kind of fills up the
volume of the cell
as a kind of branching network in there
um
and you can think of it as power cables
this is a much more efficient way of
generating energy because the charge is
distributed across the entire surface of
this network um and is much better for
distributing oxygen
around because it dissolves better in in
the fatty membranes than it does
in in aqueous solution
um and and so
it's it's probably the more efficient
way
of structuring your network to generate
power you can give it a power grid
but if you prevent it from splintering
up again
then
uh the cell would degenerate and die
it seems that it's important for
mitochondria to go back to being little
independent sausage-shaped things and if
you stop them from doing that then the
system doesn't work so why
well
because with this independent
sausage-shaped thing you can sequester a
copy of the mitochondrial dna
so now what we have
is a little sausage
with a genome of its own
and that genome is responsible for
making sure respiration works in that
mitochondrion so it's it it generates an
electrical charge on the membrane in its
own little sausage thing
so now we have a relationship between a
genotype and a phenotype the genotype is
that mitochondrial genome the phenotype
is the membrane potential the electrical
charge on this membrane and if if this
mitochondrial dna is damaged it's
mutated and it can't generate membrane
potential then the the cell machinery
can see that and kill it at that point
so it's a quality control mechanism
um
and if you if what you have is an open
network with let's say you know 500
copies of mitochondrial dna in there and
one of them's got mutations selection
can never see it because it's
effectively
its effect is is hidden by the 499 other
ones that are all contributing to the
shared common phenotype of the
electrical charge across this entire
network so you'll never notice it so you
can't get rid of it so more mutations
can happen
so so the very fact that we all have
mitochondria which are still functional
after two billion years of evolution
is because the selection on the
mitochondrial dna which is because of
sequestration
of the mitochondria within
the eukaryotic cell and that is the
difference between
lots of e coli between a planet full of
bacteria that basically can never
get beyond bacteria and the planet full
of eukaryotic life plants and animals
and everything else
that's the result of sequestration of
bacteria inside other cells with their
own dna now i don't know if that's what
he had in mind but that's what comes to
my mind when when when you asked me
about that
sure and now a near final question comes
from user rh0d3z
which says this is much more of a
technical question what are proflain's
views on mitochondrial resperosomes
slash supercomplexes in disease this may
be particularly important seeing that
they can omit complex ii and bypass
krebs cycle pathways
yes um very interesting question there
are actually some recently there's uh
there's one super complex has been
discovered with uh with complex two in
it uh but mostly
whoever asked the question is quite
right complex two is not normally part
of it um
so for people who don't know
um the the super complexes
normally what you have or normally how
we're taught and what we imagine is that
we have four or five complexes from
complex one complex two complex three
complex four and the electrons pass from
one to the next one to the next one and
so on um complex two is always a little
bit on the side in that sense
uh they go from complex one to complex
three and then to complex four then
dental oxygen
um
now
the respirosome or the super complexes
are where these complexes are brought
together very often with a specific
stoichiometry so you might have uh two
complex ones and and one complex three
and one complex four or various other
stoichiometries of these things where
you have fixed numbers of these things
they fit together in snug ways
and
until about ten years ago
um it was their existence was kind of
denied almost it was it's quite
difficult to demonstrate that they
really do exist that they're really real
now it's generally established that they
are and there's a lot of cryo-electron
microscopy shows that these things are
real
um but there's a lot that's still not
known about them do they really speed up
respiration for example
seems that they do
um but there's you know it's early days
in in this field now the specific bit
about complex ii
as part of the krebs cycle it's the only
enzyme in the krebs cycle which is
anchored into the membrane itself
and which is
effectively passing electrons directly
but it's excluded from these
supercomplexes
um how that works i
don't know
uh
there's a i i think it's
that i mean there's some very strange
factors here so so so complex one is the
only one that that oxidizes nadh and i
don't want to get too technical here but
it's the only one which is really
capable of spinning the whole krebs
cycle
so if complex one is is deficient or
broken then the krebs cycle can't work
properly
um
if it's part of a respirosome it's
likely to be operating at a faster rate
and it's likely to spin the krebs cycle
faster than it would otherwise be able
to spin but it also depends on the
structure of the christie and all kinds
of other factors so there's a kind of
macromolecular scale of organization of
mitochondria that we don't know a lot
about yet
uh and it's definitely important i
mentioned fission and fusion of
mitochondrial networks and you know all
of this is is linked it's a very dynamic
system
uh so
the interesting thing about complex two
is it pumps fewer protons
than complex if you if you if you put
electrons into complex two
and then they go into three and then
four you can pump a total of six protons
whereas if you put them into complex one
they can pump a total of ten
protons so you may think then that
there's more
power if you like but it's actually it's
not power so much as gearing
so it's like being if you're using
complex one it's like being in in a high
gear on a bike you can be in tenth gear
or something and you you can coast very
easily along along a flat road but if
you get onto a hill then you want to go
down to a lower gear
and a lower gear in the mitochondria if
you're putting if you're putting
electrons into complex two
effectively uh you've got almost the
same amount of power which is to say the
the the the
energy that's released when the
electrons that go into complex two get
through to oxygen is not quite as much
as when it's coming from nadh but it's
nearly the same
but that total energy amount is only
pumping six protons rather than ten
protons so you've got nearly the same
energy pumping fewer protons and that
means you can pump them against a higher
potential
it's you can go uphill now
you can effectively
um
switch down to you know second or third
gear or something and and keep on going
now how all of this works itself out in
terms of super complexes and christy
structure and everything else i don't
really know it will have a feedback
effect on the krebs cycle because the
krebs cycle needs to go through this
step if it's not going to
increase succinate levels which leak out
and that's an epigenetic switch which
switches genes on and off
this is
it's hardly been
explored
i mean this is a fantastic thing about
science we in some ways we seem to know
so much and in other ways there's this
kind of jungle of of dynamic
mitochondria that are changing shape
that are forming christie's that have
got an organization they're probably
generating electric magnetic fields that
are forming super complexes that are
have they you know if you've got a
closed christie structure and you're
pumping protons into it
there's a you know the limits that
you can
generate you can generate a higher
membrane potential if you put succinate
in a complex two than if you put an adh
unit complex one so you have this
th
and we can hardly measure any of this
the differences in membrane potential is
only
hardly been touched on
um between one christian and other
christians if you've got a super complex
or you don't have super complex as if
complex two is part of it or not part of
it you know there's a world out there
that we've barely discovered and it's a
world frankly of physics
this is
this is about charge and it's about
pushing against charge and this the
power and it's the energetics of the
whole thing so it's it's not
conventional biology but this is
to my mind where biology needs to go
thank you
professor and we didn't get to talk
maybe next time we can talk about if we
if i'm so blessed just to be with you
again thank you to talk about the
reverse krebs cycle and
it
aging
be a pleasure to come back that was a
lot of fun thank you yeah do you mind
ending by reading the poem from the last
chapter or the last bit of your book i
believe it's a short poem
i'm happy to do that do i have a copy of
the book anywhere near
um i have to go and get one just give me
a moment
i don't know that this will make sense
to anybody who hasn't read the book but
it's a it's a it's a beautiful poem
anyway
uh
i don't know how much sense it would
make
even without the context of the book yes
so this is like most revelations by
richard howard
it is the movement that incites the form
discovered as a downward rapture yes it
is the movement that delights the form
sustained by its own velocity
and yet it is the movement that delays
the form while darkness slows and
encumbers in fact it is the movement
that betrays the form baffled in such
toils of ease until it is the movement
that deceives the form beguiling our
attention we suppose it is the movement
that achieves the form were we mistaken
what does it matter if it is the
movement that negates the form
even though we give give up ourselves to
this mortal process of continuing
it is the movement that creates the form
oh
well thank you
thank you professor for being with me
with the tow audience for
for so long
thank you for having me on it's been a
pleasure
okay all right thank you thank you for
sticking around for two and a half hours
maybe maybe longer i appreciate that i
hope that it was enjoyable to you again
there's the website theoriesofthing.org
that's a place that you can go to
support toe if you're interested in that
like i mentioned in the intro there are
several benefits you get an ads free
audio version you get that
sometimes 12 to 48 hours to a few days
prior to premiering on youtube you get
discounts to the live events when we
finally do have them sometimes those
tickets may even be free so for instance
i'm looking into doing something with
john verveiki and ian mcgillcrist in
person this is all extremely tentative
right now but this is a plan to do in
the future carl fristen in london live
in front of an audience is another
example there will be exclusive merch
and so on there's quite a few benefits
you can text me if you like there's a
number at least we're testing that for
about one week or one month or so again
that's theoriesofthing.org
thank you all for watching it's great to
see you in the live chat i appreciate
all of the love thank you thank you so
much
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to
theoriesofeverything.org
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you
you